[Musique]
merci beaucoup alors effectivement pour
ceux d'entre vous qui sont pressés parce
qu'ils doivent aller à un match de
tennis une soirée ou autre activité
essentielle de cette nature le digital
c'est aujourd'hui une des activités dont
l'empreinte carbone croît le plus vite
sur terre
donc c'est pas du tout quelque chose qui
dématérialise et qui permet de faire
baisser les émissions ça comme effet
l'exact inverse mais j'y viendrai à la
fin vous êtes exposés
puisque comme on m'a appris à l'école je
vais essayer de prendre le problème par
le début donc il est question de vous
parler de transition énergétique alors
j'ai changé de titre à la dernière
minute finalement j'ai décidé que je
pourquoi le grand machin rallonge que je
vous proposais c'était moins parlants
que ce que je vous propose maintenant
en fait ce que je vais vous montrer
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes lost in
transition c'est à dire que ont fait une
transition bon c'est pas trop pour
laquelle est ni pourquoi est une des
raisons à cela c'est que le problème à
traiter est mal compris en règle
générale il fait l'objet d'énormément de
malentendus alors qu'ils sont assez
faciles à comprendre quand on prend le
temps mais malheureusement il faut
prendre le temps donc on va parler de
transition énergétique et alors on va
faire comme au bac de philo auquel vous
avez dû sacrifier il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça puisqu'on va parler de
transition énergétique on va s'occuper
des mots qui a une transition
énergétique et je vais commencer par le
second c'est à dire énergétique et on va
donc commencer par discuter d'énergie
alors voilà le prof le plus connu de
france beaucoup plus connus de tous aux
enseignants 6 millions d'élèves à chaque
fois enfin maintenant il est parti à la
retraite soit disant et vous savez qu'en
général ils demandaient pour la question
à un million est ce que
figure qui est en haut à gauche du
timbre de 84 centimes est en train de se
gratter le nez ou de se regarder les
pieds bon là en l'occurrence on pas
imaginer qu'il pose une question qui est
beaucoup plus triviale beaucoup plus
simple savait qu'en france il ya un
ministre chargé de l'énergie
donc on va demander à la population
française d'après vous c'est quoi
l'énergie moi je vous fiche mon billet
que si je pose la question y compris aux
ministres chargés de l'énergie 9 fois
sur 10 je obtenir une mauvaise réponse
qui est pas exactement celle qui ferait
à voir en fait si vous demandez aux
français ce que c'est que l'énergie la
majeure partie de mes concitoyens vont
vous faire une réponse assez simple qui
est ça
quelle énergie et une facture donc
l'énergie c'est un truc qu'on paye et du
reste je vais vous montrer que c'est pas
un gros souci de deux manières
différentes qui dans cette salle et
occupant de son logement et paye ses
factures d'électricité dans les gens qui
viennent de lever la main qui connaît le
montant de sa dernière facture à l'euro
près 1
maintenant qui dans cette salle est
locataire d'accord alors parmi les gens
qui viennent de lever la main qui
connaît le montant de son dernier loyer
c'est à peu près les mêmes d'accord donc
ce que je viens de vous montrer avec ce
petit est très simple c'est que en fait
l'énergie c'est quelque chose que c'est
une facture certes dans l'esprit de
beaucoup de gens mais c'est une petite
facture en fait dont on n'y fait pas
attention parce que si on prend les
choses sous cet angle en fait c'est pas
beaucoup si vous rapportez la totalité
des dépenses pour l'énergie dans le
monde à la totalité de ce que les gens
gagnent donc c'est très simple calcul
que j'ai fait j'ai pris la totalité de
l'argent qu'on dépense pour acheter du
pétrole du gaz du charbon pas encore d
énergie transformer en du pétrole du gaz
du charbon
eh eh bien j'arrive au fait que ces
quelques pourcents de ce que les gens
gagnent dans le monde et à ce moment ci
on voit l'énergie comme une facture le
réflexe qu'on va avoir c'est je vais
m'en occuper quelques pour cent du temps
et puis le reste du temps je m'en
occuperai pas du reste je suis sûr que
monsieur koala ne s'occupe pas d'énergie
h 24 il s'occupe éventuellement
d'énergie le jour où on vient de voir en
lisant la facture d'électricité est un
peu élevé le reste du temps il s'en fout
comme de l'an 40 parce que ça fait
absolument pas partie de son écran radar
est son tableau de bord
c'est pas dans les trucs qu'on lui
demande de gérer alors si je fais cette
analogie c'est pour dire que
malheureusement ce que vous allez
comprendre dans pas longtemps c'est que
cette façon de voir les choses est aussi
pertinente que si je dis votre cervelle
ces 2 % de votre masse donc vous pouvez
vous en occuper ou bien la traiter 2 %
du temps du temps c'est pas la peine
c'est juste 2 % de votre poids d'accord
si je vous en enlève la moitié des vins
vous ferez 1% - performance pas très
grave vous arriverez encore à trouver
des employeurs alors évidemment ce
raisonnement est complètement invalides
en fait ce raisonnement en part de
camembert vous savez en pourcentage
masquer le lien de dépendance d'une part
de camembert à une autre part de
camembert donc c'est peut-être 2 % de
votre poids votre cervelle mais vous
êtes 100% dépendant de son existence et
vous avez dans votre corps un certain
nombre de glande qui produisent des
hormones dont soit le poids de la glande
soit le poids des hormones est
considérablement inférieur à 2 % de
votre poids et pourtant si je vous les
enlève je vous fiche le bazar dans votre
organisme donc l'énergie c'est peut-être
quelques pourcents de ce qu'on dépense
mais ce que vous allez comprendre c'est
que c'est 100 % de ce qui fait le monde
moderne et qui vous a notamment permis
d'arriver dans cet amphi au lieu d'être
occupés à ramasser des patates donc la
bonne réponse c'est pas que c'est une
facture ou plus exactement oui c'est une
facture mais c'est une manière
anecdotique de voir le problème
alors après il ya un deuxième slogan qui
a été treize ans le deuxième réflexe
pavlovien on va dire quand on parle
d'énergie c'est faut l'économiser
là vous avez tous entendu ce slogan la
meilleure énergie est celle qu'on
n'utilise pas les bains c'est une énorme
âneries la meilleure énergie est bien
celle qu'on utilise
et c'est bien parce qu'on sait gober
goberger d'énergie jusqu'à maintenant de
manière croissante que la civilisation
technologique a pu émerger
sinon vous seriez
tellement inutile moi aussi du reste je
vous montrais dans pas longtemps
troisième réflexe pavlovien l'énergie il
faut la faire 100% renouvelable alors
certainement sauf que quand on regarde
d'un peu près ce qui vient de se passer
sur les deux siècles qui nous ont
précédés en fait on a passé notre temps
à faire l'exact inverse
on avait par exemple une marine 100%
renouvelable que voici avec des voiles
en coton et en lin parfaitement
renouvelables propulsé par le vent
parfaitement renouvelables construite
avec du bois parfaitement renouvelables
et on s'est dit quand même pour faire
venir aux ordinateurs de taïwan chine
c'est quand même vachement au lieu
d'avoir de la marine fossiles ça marche
mieux
ensuite on avait des transports
terrestres parfaitement renouvelables
donc on avait des animaux renouvelables
mangeant de l'herbe renouvelables tirant
des charrettes en bois renouvelables etc
et on s'est dit non quand même pour
alimenter le supermarché c'est quand
même vachement au lieu d'avoir des
transports fossiles c'est quand même
plus efficace
on avait une agriculture 100%
renouvelable voyez avec des engins de
traction parfaitement renouvelables
mangeant une nourriture parfaitement
renouvelables qui s'appelle de l'herbe
puis on s'est dit non quand même pour
avoir un big mac qui n'en parlons pas de
pub à quelques euros seulement c'est
quand même vachement au lieu d'avoir une
agriculture fossiles ça marche bien et
puis on avait des travaux publics
parfaitement renouvelables donc il
fallait des pelles et des pioches pour
faire les voies romaines et puis on
s'est dit non quand même pour faire des
ronds points c'est très important et en
coin dans notre pays et bien c'est quand
même beaucoup plus efficace d'avoir des
travaux publics fossiles ça marche bien
on avait de la construction parfaitement
renouvelables donc un siècle pour faire
notre dame en v1 ou v2 ça ira plus vite
ou bien un an pour faire des grands
cornichons à la défense maintenant grâce
à la construction fossiles c'est quand
même beaucoup plus efficace on avait une
industrie parfaitement renouvelables
avec des moulins à eau parfaitement
renouvelables et des forges utilisant du
poids en fait qui était pas du tout
renouvelable ça va contribuer à la
déforestation en france et on s'est
rendu compte que pour faire
vos baskets vos meubles vos tableaux
chaises evolis était quand même beaucoup
plus efficace d'avoir une industrie
fossiles que ça marche est vachement
mieux
donc on s'est dépêché de le faire et
enfin on avait même des séchoirs à
luzerne qui sait parfaitement
renouvelables s'appelait le soleil et
aujourd'hui on a des séchoirs à l'usam à
gaz que voici donc on a passé notre
temps sur les deux derniers siècles à
passer du renouvelable aux fossiles
alors de deux choses l'une ou bien nos
ancêtres étaient des crétins patenté
puisque il faut faire 100% renouvelable
ou bien il ya une raison physique à ça
et en fait il ya une raison physique à
ça et alors normalement tous les gens
qui sont rentrés dans cet amphi savent
que négocier avec les lois de la
physique c'est compliqué c'est on peut
les connaître on peut les apprivoiser on
peut les exploiter à notre profit mais
l'échangé parce qu'elle nous déplaisent
ça marche pas bien quoi est ce que vous
allez comprendre
parce que ça va être un des propos de
pendant la conférence c'est de vous
montrer que malheureusement une partie
de la transition qu'on essaye de faire
en ce moment dans les pays occidentaux
c'est justement penser qu'on va changer
les lois de la physique par un vote à
l'assemblée nationale voilà donc je
poursuis prêt à prendre les paris sur
mes propres économies contre qui veut
que c'est pas complètement sûr que ça
marche
donc on a trois mauvaises réponses est
en fait la bonne réponse
la voici l'énergie c'est ce qui nous a
permis de devenir superman pour de vrai
l'énergie c'est ce qui permet de voler
la comme l'individu qui a traversé la
manche ou bien quand on vous met dans
une grosse boîte de conserve qui
s'appelle n'avions l'énergie c'est ce
qui permet de se déplacer à 800
kilomètres heure de ne pas avoir chaud
de ne pas avoir froid de soulever des
charges absolument monstrueux ça
s'appelle un tractopelle ou une machine
à une grue c'est de tout transformer à
la vitesse de la lumière
donc on est devenus superman pour de
vrai grâce à l'énergie c'est en fait ça
l'énergie et c'est justement pour ça qu
on a moyen envie de s'en passer
alors si je reviens maintenant à des
choses qui vous ont un peu fait mal à la
tête
dans vos jeunes années enfin gros plus
j'aime ça n'est plus exactement on va
revenir à de la physique de base
ça va permettre de mieux comprendre de
quoi on parle
en fait l'énergie vous l'avez tous vu
dans les merveilleuses exercice qu'on
vous a demandé de résoudre pour entrer
ici je pourrai le résumer en disant que
c'est ce qui permet de quantifier le
changement d'état d'un système d'accord
c'est sur l'énergie c'est ce qui
quantifie le changement d'état d'un
système quand vous avez un système qui
change de température de vitesse de
forme de composition chimique de
composition atomique de position dans un
champ avec lequel il interagit etc
n'importe lequel de ces changements mais
enjeux de l'énergie et d'une manière
générale plus vous avez d'énergie qui
entrent en jeu
plus la transformation est importante et
symétriquement plus la transformation
est importante plus de l'énergie est
entré en jeu donc l'énergie
c'est pas juste un machin qu'on manipule
comme ça histoire de faire des débats
sympathique pour savoir si on est pour
ou contre l'éolien
avant toute chose c'est une grandeur
physique régis par des lois qui ne
dépendent pas de nous et cette grandeur
physique elle quand ici le changement
d'état des systèmes c'est-à-dire qu'elle
quantifie la transformation de
l'environnement
et dire qu'on utilise de plus en plus
d'énergie ça n'est rien d'autre que de
dire qu'on est capable de transformer de
plus en plus vite environnement
c'est juste ça que c'était avec ses
effets bénéfiques et ses effets
désagréables
alors comme vous le savez l'énergie
comme toutes grandeurs physiques comme
je le disais est soumise à des lois
qu'on ne modifie pas par un vote à
l'assemblée nationale et alors y en a
une que vous connaissez évidemment je
pense que je vous la connaissez pas
c'est quand même un peu ennuyeux vu les
études que vous êtes en train de faire
qui est la loi de conservation au
premier principe de la thermodynamique
et cette loi dit un truc très bête qui
est dans un système qu'ils communiquent
pas avec l'extérieur la quantité
d'énergie se conserve rigoureusement au
cours du temps si j'applique ça à
l'humanité ça veut dire que l'humanité
chaque être vivant tant qu'ils ne
communiquent pas avec l'extérieur il ne
peut pas disposer d'énergie
c'est tout con sinon vous seriez merlin
l'enchanteur ce que vous n'êtes pas donc
pour utiliser de l'énergie
en fait en pratique il faut aller la
chercher dans l'environnement là où elle
est déjà et la mettre dans un
convertisseur qui va pouvoir qui va
permettre de nous rendre un service
ce qui en pratique et transformer
l'énergie un autre chose le premier
convertisseur que nous avons eu à notre
disposition historiquement c'est nous
mêmes nous sommes des machines à
transformer l'énergie
on transforme l'énergie chimique
contenue dans nos aliments en mouvement
un peu chaleur beaucoup donc c'est nous
sommes des convertisseurs d'énergie
nous ne sommes malheureusement que ce
ariège plus qui a dit nous ne sommes que
chimie une somme que convertisseur un
très agréable
donc c'est le ces convertisseurs
historique en utiliser l'énergie
historique qu'on utilise c'est celle qui
est contenu dans les aliments c'est à
dire c'est de l'énergie
photosynthétiques séquestrés c'est ça le
csa l'énergie qu'on utilise et puis avec
le temps on s'est rendu compte qu'on
pouvait utiliser d'autres convertisseur
à notre profit alors la première chose
qu'on a faite c'est d'utiliser d'autres
convertisseur biologique qu'on a
domestiqué ou a servi donc c'est soit
les animaux domestiques sur les esclaves
la corse et d'autres convertisseur
biologique puis on les exploite
ça permet de transformer plus vite tu
environnement pour les hommes qui ne
sont pas pardon des esclaves ensuite on
a découvert qu'on pouvait aux
domestiques et des énergies non
biologique enfin des convertisseurs non
biologique
au travers du feu de la force du vent de
la force de l'eau etc
donc on a développé toutes les énergies
renouvelables et puis là dessus ou à de
papin et leurs petits copains sont
arrivés et ont dit on peut faire
beaucoup mieux que sarlat vous avez rien
vu jusqu'à maintenant on va utiliser des
convertisseurs fait de métal ça va
s'appeler les machines et alors là vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir en
terme de puissance disponible et de
capacité à transformer l'environnement
est en fait le l'histoire de l'énergie
chez les hommes c'est l'histoire de la
domestication d'un nombre croissant de
convertisseurs ou d'un nombre croissant
de types de convertisseurs et d'un
nombre croissant de sources d'énergie
existant déjà dans l'environnement
ce qui veut dire que utiliser de
l'énergie à partir de maintenant vous
barrez énergie et vous remplacez par
machine ou par convertisseur la
convertisseur c'est un peu plus
compliqué à comprendre mais vous
remplacez par machine donc utiliser de
plus en plus d'énergie en fait ça porte
un nom extrêmement simple c'est utiliser
de plus en plus de machines et donc
c'est pour ça que à chaque fois qu'on
augmente peu de consommation d'énergie
on augmente notre capacité à transformer
l'environnement dans un temps donné
ces machines elles sont pas elles ne
sont pas petit par rapport à nos
carcasse est soi-même surpuissante par
rapport à dos carcasse on va imaginer
que comme vous êtes jeune et sportif
vous alliez faire tous les matins avant
de vous avant de prendre le petit
déjeuner pour vous mettre en forme de
1000 mètres de dénivelé
enfin une ascension de 2000 mètres de
dénivelé donc une ascension de 1000
mètres de dénivelé cécilia 6,6 fois
l'ascension de la tour eiffel à pied
voilà je vais pas compter le nombre de
fois où vous devriez monter la butte
montmartre sommes enfin vous pourrez le
faire aussi bien que moi et si vous
faites ce genre d'exercice qui est un
exercice qui est quand même sympathique
un touché la moitié de l'ascension
chamonix mont blanc fait bien dans la
journée ça fait un petit truc sympa
et bien une fois que vous avez fait cet
effort la quantité d'énergie que vous
avez fourni et un ridicule demi
kilowattheure si vous faites est galen g
h avec un corps enfin une masse de 90 kg
et une ascension de 2000 mètres vous
vous retrouvez avec 1,8 mégajoule
c'est-à-dire un demi kilo watt heure
donc vos jambes ayant fourni un effort
assez significatif sur une journée tout
ce que j'ai à l'arrivée c'est un devis
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique si
j'imagine que vous faites ça un jour sur
deux vous faites une étape du gr20 tous
les jours que dieu fait et bien à la fin
de l'année vous aurez fournit 100
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique donc
retenu les cadors au travail de force
avec son organisme en utilisant les plus
puissantes ses membres c'est-à-dire ses
jambes est capable de fournir 100
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique sur
une journée sur une année pardon en gros
si vous utilisez non pas vos jambes mais
vos bras et puis un petit peu votre dos
aussi qui aura mal et que vous des quais
ses six mètres cubes de terre dans une
journée la densité de la terre étant ce
qu'elle est ça fait quinze tonnes et
galen g h toujours et bien vous êtes dix
fois plus ridicule que mon alpinistes
c'est 0.05 kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique que vous fournissez en une
journée avec 15 tonnes de terre décaissé
d'art être et si vous faites ça un jour
sur deux à la fin de l'année ses 10
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique que
vous aurez fourni or il se trouve que 10
kilowatts heure c'est la quantité
d'énergie thermique pas mécanique mais
thermique que vous avez dans la
combustion d'un seul litre d'essence
un litre d'essence pas 253 ou 3000 1
litre d'essence qui coûte comme chacun
sait le prix scandaleusement élevé de 1
euro 50
donc dans un litre d'essence vous avez
des kilowattheures d'énergie thermique
alors vous comme vos petits copains des
ponts et des mines savent pas faire des
machines de carnot avec un rendement de
1 se demandant ce qu'ils foutent
et bien vous n'avez avec ses 10
kilowatts heure que 2 à 4 kilowatts
heure d'énergie mécanique en sortie il
n'empêche que dans 1 litre de pétrole
passant dans une machine vous avez quand
même la même capacité à transformer
l'environnement que dans 10 à 100 jours
de travail de force d'un être humain
dans 10h et pardon oui c'est ça ou 10 10
500 personnes travaillant sur un jour
dans un lit de pétrole d'accord donc
avec 3 litres de pétrole vous vous
achetez entre guillemets la même
capacité à transformer l'environnement
qu'un être humain travaillant avec ses
bras toute l'année je sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte
donc ce qui a fait la productivité du
travail
c'est ça ce qui a fait la hausse du
pouvoir d'achat parce que la hausse de
la production
c'est ça ce qui a fait toute l'évolution
du 19e et du 20e siècle tient dans ces
facteur multiplicatif tout ce qui tient
également dansé facteur multiplicatif
c'est ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler la
hausse de la productivité du travail
parce que le mec le kilowattheure humain
qui si je paye mon employé au smic
valley en prix d'aujourd'hui quelques
centaines à quelques milliers d'euros
je les remplacer par un kilowattheure de
machines qui encourage inhalent me coûte
quelques dizaines de centimes
c'est à dire quelques centaines à
quelques milliers de fois moins que ce
que me coûte l'être humain au travail
donc en fait la formidable hausse de la
productivité du travail
le fait que les gens soient devenus
considérablement plus productifs c'est
pas juste parce qu'on est intelligent ou
c'est pas parce que vous êtes tous
devenus shiva avec 98 paires de bras et
253 paire de jambes
c'est parce que nous nous sommes adjoint
des machines qui travaillent pour nous
et qu'on continue à mettre au
dénominateur simplement les gens qui
existe sur terre c'est ça la raison
fondamentale de la hausse de la
productivité du travail s'est pas venue
de mars
c'est venu de l'énergie et des machines
imaginons maintenant je prenne un
esclave il ya eu des esclaves dans le
monde souvent à l'esclave
il est exactement comme les autres êtres
humains c'est à dire qu' il n'a que sa
puissance musculaire à sa disposition
et puis en général esclaves c'est pas
une vocation de jeunesse donc quand vous
utilisez un esclave
vous allez devoir aller le chercher
contre sa volonté l'empêcher de vous
trucider l'empêcher de fiche le camp le
nourrir le vêtir et c est bien quand
vous regardez ce que vous coûte le
kilowatt heure de travail d'esclave avec
tous les dépenses que je viens d'évoquer
vous vous rendez compte que ça coûte
encore 10 à 100 fois plus cher que la
machine qui est pas syndiqués qui
travaillent à joindre ktk strictement
rien quand sa condition de machines la
raison pour laquelle l'esclavagisme a
disparu dans le monde tant l'essentiel
du monde
c'est pas parce que notre code génétique
fait de nous aujourd'hui d être
fondamentalement bon alors qu'il ya deux
ans nous étions fondamental de siècle
par dont nous étions fondamentalement
malfaisants c'est pas du tout ça qui a
fait disparaître les esclaves ce qui a
fait disparaître les esclaves c'est le
pétrole c'est la machine qui a fait
disparaître les esclaves parce que ça
n'a strictement aucune espèce d'intérêt
de s'emmerder à servir son semblable
alors que ce qu'on a fait encore une
fois pendant des millénaires des
millénaires les citoyens libres de rome
était assis sur une armée d'esclaves qui
cultivaient leurs nourritures pour eux
le servage a existé pendant tout le
moyen âge enfin d'une part la seule
l'esclavagisme pendant tous les romains
le servage quoi en tout moyen-âge et
c'est donc ce calibre les esclaves c'est
les machines c'est à dire l'énergie
j'ai raisonné énergie je peux réseau des
puissances je vais arriver à des
conclusions similaires
donc mon grand bonheur du gr20 là il me
fournit une puissance moyenne qui se
balade entre 100 watts il utilise ses
jambes et d'iwate si c'est un
antipodistes nom et d'iwate
si elle te de la terre le premier
tracteur venu développe la même
puissance que quelques centaines de
paires de jambes où soit dit en passant
quelques dizaines de vrais chevaux dont
vous donnez un tracteur un agriculteur
exit quelques centaines d'autres
agriculteurs qui ne sont absolument plus
nécessaire pour les travaux mécaniques
deschamps exit les animaux très qui soit
dit en passant nous faisait concurrence
sur l'usagé des sols je vous signale que
le gros inconvénient des animaux très
c'est qu'ils ont besoin de la surface de
la même surface que celle qui nous est
utile pour manger pour manger eux donc
un monde avec eux des tracteurs et pas
d'animaux de très peu et bergers est
beaucoup plus d'êtres humains que si on
a besoin de revenir aux animaux très
pour remplacer les tracteurs un engin de
travaux publics développe la même
puissance que quelques milliers de
paires de bras
c'est la raison pour laquelle on peut
construire une maison en quelques mois
pour le prix de quelques années de
salaire ça et les cimenteries et autres
machines qu'on a mise en service un
camion développe la même puissance que
quelques milliers de fois les jambes de
son conducteur un avion un million de
fois les jambes du pilote et un laminoir
ça développe la même puissance que toute
l'île de france à qui j'aurais donné un
marteau pour taper sur des tôles oui si
je supprime le laminoir de fos-sur-mer
pour créer de l'emploi et remplacer sa
part des franciliens qui tape sur
l'épaule il ya plus d'étudiants à
telecom voilà c'est plus la peine de
venir vous enquiquiner à écouter les
profs vous avez un marteau et vous tapez
sur des tôles toute la journée vous plus
tous les autres tous les franciliens moi
aussi
donc ce petit inventaire très rapide
parce qu'il ya évidemment pas que ces
machines là dans le monde qui nous
entoure vous montre à quel point nous
avons construit un monde fait de
monstres d'acier et de métaux divers qui
sont nos esclaves des temps modernes et
qui travaillent pour nous c'est très
exactement ça qu'ils ont qui sont qui
l'ont fait alors la nourriture de ces
esclaves des temps modernes
voilà comment elle a évolué vous avez
ici la quantité d'énergie
je sais pas si je dois dire utiliser ou
consommer j'ai pas tellement le mo
consommés en ce qui concerne l'énergie
puisque l'énergie peut pas se détruire
donc ce mot consommer on devrait dire
transformer en fait si on était
orthodoxe on devrait pas dire production
d'énergie on devrait dire extraction ou
transformation d'énergie et on devrait
pas dire consommation d'énergie on
devrait dire usage ou à nous aux
transformations
donc on va dire usage ce que vous voyez
c'est qu'il ya un siècle et demi
nos ancêtres alors ça c'est une moyenne
mondiale
utilisé en moyenne 5000 kilowattheures
par an c'était essentiellement du bois
et ça servait à l'époque essentiellement
à se chauffer et alimenter les forges et
à alimenter les premières machines à
vapeur
et puis avec le temps lusage du bois par
personne tend à diminuer j'y viens par
personne parce que au total c'est pareil
et vous voyez apparaître d'autres usages
qui vont se développer alors le premier
usage qui va se développer c'est le
charbon le charbon alimente au début les
machines à vapeur et la production
d'acier aujourd'hui son usage dominant
c'est la production électrique les deux
tiers du charbon extrait d'une mine dans
le monde finissent leur vie dans une
centrale électrique est symétriquement
la production électrique au charbon
c'est le premier mode de production
électrique dans le monde alors pourquoi
est ce qu'on produit de l'électricité
avec du charbon parce qu'une centrale
électrique dans le monde c'est pour
l'essentiel une machine de carnot là
aussi on produit de la chaleur en grande
quantité avec laquelle on produit de la
vapeur avec laquelle on fait tourner une
turbine
c'est vrai des centrales à charbon des
centrales à gaz des centrales à pétrole
des centrales nucléaires des centrales à
biogaz cordes et vous avez une chance de
chaleur c'est comme ça que ça marche
et soit dit en passant dès que vous avez
une source de chaleur monsieur carnot
étant inflexible vous avez n'importe
quoi entre 50 et 70 % de la chaleur
initial qui part au petit oiseau
parce que à moins tu es de sûreté en ce
que vous voyez c'est que l'essentiel
pardon c'est que la quantité de charbon
utilisé par personne n'a jamais décru
depuis qu'on a commencé à utiliser du
charbon j'avais et les français ont
fortement augmenté récemment leur
consommation de charbon a fumé la
moquette ou sk une mine de charbon en
france il n'y a pas de mine de charbon
en france mais ça c'est made in charbon
made in china made in japon et d'une
manière générale toutes nos importations
made in china ou made in india ou made
in taiwan sont made in charbon une large
partie de japon
c'est aussi made in charbon ce qui
concerne la production électrique etc
donc les français comme il importe de
plus en plus de biens manufacturés en
fait ils augmentent leur quantité de
charbon consommé par personne ils se
rendent pas compte mais c'est ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire
par-dessus le charbon est pas du tout en
remplacement et ariel pétrole alors le
pétrole à un usage très différent du
charbon il se trouve que le pétrole et
l'énergie qui permet d'avoir la plus
grande quantité de kilowattheures par
unité de poids de toutes celles que nous
manipulons or l'uranium mais c'est un
peu particulier
ce que c'est difficile d'emmener son
petit réacteur nucléaire dans sa voiture
donc pour toutes les autres énergies
la densité d'énergie maximale par unité
de volume ou par unité de poids est à
peindre pour le pétrole
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle le
pétrole s'est imposé dans la mobilité
alors que la première voiture a dépassé
les 100 kilomètres heure était une
voiture électrique comme vous le savez
peut-être la jamais contente au début du
20e siècle est la raison pour laquelle
c'est pas la voiture électrique qui a
percé alors qu'on essaye de la faire
percer aujourd'hui c'est parce que la
densité d'énergie dans un kg de
batteries est considérablement plus
faible que la densité d'énergie dans un
kilo de pétrole dans un kg de batteries
plomb acide vous mettez 35 watts heure
dans un kg de batteries lithium vous
mettez 10 fois sa 300 dans un kilo de
pétrole vous mettez 12 kilowatts heure
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle le
pétrole s'est imposé dans la mobilité
est aujourd'hui 98 % de ce qui roule vol
où naviguent utilise du pétrole donc
c'est vraiment l'énergie darren de la
mobilité
le gaz est venue se rajouter par-dessus
l'hydroélectricité du sras ajouté par
dessus le nucléaire et alors là ça c'est
ce qui excite tout le monde des
nouvelles énergies renouvelables
l'éolien le solaire le machin etc
alors quand vous regardez les ordres de
grandeurs question comme je vais vous
dire à la fin de cet exposé si on veut
pas trop faire les zazous avec le
changement climatique
c'est mal parti soit dit en passant il
faut que la totalité des émissions
mondiales et disparus dans les quarante
ans qui viennent question est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est essentiellement en
comptant sur ses trois trucs là qu'on va
y arriver
moi quand je vois les ordres de
grandeurs je vais pas sûr
peut-être qu'on ferait bien d'explorer
d'autres trucs
[Musique]
la réalité du monde d'aujourd'hui c'est
que l'essentiel de l'énergie qui permet
de faire fonctionner le parc de machines
qui fait nous superman ou super grumman
c'est des énergies fossiles et c'est
toujours autant d énergie fossile que
depuis qu on s'excite sur le changement
climatique dans les discours la quantité
d'énergie qui est mise à la disposition
de chaque terrien actionne un parc de
machines par terriens qui a multiplié la
puissance musculaire de chaque terrien
par environ 200 donc en fait grâce à
l'énergie et aux machines la force
productive de l'humanité aujourd'hui
c'est pas celle de 7 millions de bons
hommes c'est celle de 1400 millions 1,1
milliard par dans deux bonshommes
d'accord si on n'avait pas les machines
et l'énergie pour avoir la même
production que celles qu'on a sur terre
il faut des jus avec juste des muscles
il faudrait être 1400 milliards de bons
hommes sur terre
bon ça poserait un tout petit sujets
agricoles des espaces
évidemment qu'on n'y arriverait pas je
vous le dis encore autrement ça veut
dire que le terrien ordinaire vie comme
si il avait 200 esclaves à sa
disposition h 24
le français ordinaire pour lui ça va
plutôt grâce à ce costume de superman
être six ans et les gens qui sont dans
cette salle moi inclus comme vous faites
partie des catégories
socioprofessionnelles supérieures c'est
plutôt entre 1000 et 2000 que ça se
baladent d'accord c'est ça la réalité du
monde qui nous entoure
alors ces esclaves des temps modernes
vous arrivez ici un tout petit sous
ensemble je dis bien un tout petit sous
ensemble vous avez des dizaines des
centaines de milliers de machines qui
bossent pour nous prenons un exemple
tout bête le fait que vous soyez tous
habillés
c'est illégal d'être tenu et bien pour
vous habiller opération qui a pris
quelques dizaines de secondes
allez quelques minutes pour les plus
lents les plus hésitants et bien vous
avez indirectement mobilisés à votre
profit des centaines des milliers des
dizaines de milliers de machines qui
travaillent dans les champs dans les
teintures dents
le filage dans le tissage dans le
transport dans la construction des
magasins dans les entrepôts des machines
absolument partout dans la fabrication
des engrais qu'on a utilisées pour les
cultures vous avez mobilisé à votre
profit des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de machines mais comme on est
tous devenus des urbains déconnecté des
flux physiques
on s'en rend pas compte encore le paysan
de l'ancien temps il comprenait bien
qu'il était dépendant de ce qui se
passait dans son champ vous ne voyez pas
les machines qui travaillent pour vous
donc vous comprenez pas que vous en êtes
dépendant
ça demande un effort intellectuel
important de se rendre compte qu'on en
indépendants mais c'est exactement ce
qui se passe quand on est dépendant de
ce pacte machine qui n'a jamais entendu
dans cette salle que la france était un
pays tout nucléaire
il y en a un qu'il y avait la presse un
deuxième nom bon donc les autres vous
avez tous entendu au détour d'un débat
télévisé d'un article de journal et
cetera que la france était un pays tout
nucléaire
alors voilà un très bel exemple de fait
qui news
il y en a 1 milliard dans la presse sur
ces sujets en un très brillant
j'ai regardé enfin pas moi mais mon
excellente équipe à carbone 4 à
tripatouiller les statistiques
nationales sur la consommation d'énergie
et on a regardé quelle était la
consommation des machines de ce pays en
fonction de l'endroit où la machine se
trouve alors si la machine se trouve
quelque part pour fabriquer un objet
s'appelle industrie que cet objet soit
une bouteille ou une paire de
chaussettes ou une pièce d'airbus et à
ce moment là si la machine sert à
déplacer des personnes ou des
marchandises
elle est dans la colonne transports si
la machine est dans un lieu où on
travaille hors fabrication d'objets ça
s'appelle tertiaire essentiellement un
bureau un hôpital une école etc
si la machine est chez vous ça s'appelle
résidentiel donc là les aspirateurs les
ascenseurs les ventilateurs tout y passe
y la dernière console de jeux
et si la machine et dans les champs
c'est lent et l'énergie qui permet à
cette machine de fonctionner a été
graduelle ici en kilowattheures au plus
vite en milliards de kilowattheures
c'est ce qu'on appelle de l'énergie
finale c'est à dire c'est l'énergie qui
rentrent dans la machine
par opposition à une énergie qu'on
appelle aussi primaire qui est l'énergie
qui rendent dans le système énergétique
donc l'énergie primaire c'est celle
qu'on prend dans l'environnement qui
rentre dans le système énergétique
d'où il sort d énergie finale de
l'électricité et des carburants raffinés
et c'est qu'ils rentrent dans les
machines entre les deux vous avez
évidemment des pertes c'est les pertes
dans la production électrique les pertes
dans leur finale et c'est donc là c'est
l'énergie finale est ici vous avez
l'énergie primaire dont est issu
l'énergie finale en question donc par
exemple tout ce qui est rouge ce qui
vient du pétrole et alors maintenant je
cercle ce qui dans notre pays vient des
combustibles fossiles et je vous pose la
question vous êtes rédacteur en chef
dans un journal et un journaliste mais
en ce qui concerne l'énergie la france
et tout nucléaire
est ce que vous laissez passer le titre
normalement non on confond en permanence
dans ce pays énergie électricité en
perds ma danse et nos débats sur
l'énergie sont avant tout des débats sur
l'électricité
alors je reviendrai peut-être vraiment
les questions il ya un milliard deux
raisons à ça mais on se focalise dans
notre pays essentiellement sur
l'électricité alors quand les gilets
jaunes gueule on se dit tiens on va
s'occuper un peu de la taxe carbone sur
les carburants
mais globalement c'est enfin voilà on le
débat est essentiellement focalisés sur
l'électricité
je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne alors il se trouve que
personne ne donne pas toute l'histoire
puisqu'il faut aussi donner le nom de
personnes sur terre
vous avez ici l'évolution de la
population humaine depuis que notre
espèce s'est sédentarisé ya à peu près
dix mille ans alors c'est par hasard que
notre espèce se soit sédentarisés ya dix
mille ans c'est parce que dix mille ans
et la fin de la dernière grande
transition climatique que nous ayons
connue nous notre espèce qui s'appelle
la déglaciation il ya vingt mille ans on
était au coeur de la dernière ère
glaciaire j'ai beaucoup plus froid j'en
parle à deux heures puis le climat s'est
réchauffé parce que le climat varie de
façon parfaitement naturel pas sur les
durée aussi courte que celle qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui
il varie de manière parfaitement naturel
et
ça à réchauffer le climat jusqu'à il ya
dix mille ans où ça s'est stabilisé et à
ce moment alors autant dans un climat
instable
c'est compliqué de se sédentariser
quelque part parce que les conditions
vont changer trop vite pour que vous
ayez le temps vous adapter en permanence
autant une fois que le climat s'est
stabilisée vous pouvez le faire donc on
s'est sédentarisé on a développé
l'agriculture les villes etc dont nous
sommes les très lointains héritiers
alors à ce moment là la planète compte
quelques millions de bipèdes n'allait
pas demander si ces 5 4,9 3,8
l'ordre de grandeur ces quelques
millions alors vous voyez que ça
augmente doucettement puisse de temps en
temps ça se contracte il ya des grandes
épidémies et puis au moment où on arrive
au début de la révolution industrielle
nous sommes un peu plus d'un milliard
pardon un peu moins d'un milliard sur
cette planète est là en l'espace de deux
siècles
on va voir la population multipliée de
façon absolument considérable est l'une
des raisons c'est précisément parce que
nous avons disposé d'énergie à profusion
qui a permis d'augmenter la production
agricole qui a peu pas d'abord
d'augmenter les les auxiliaires agricole
puis ensuite le directement les machines
dans les champs de le conserver les
aliments d'avoir de la prophylaxie et
c'est donc le fait qu'on soit
aujourd'hui quelques milliards sur terre
doit à l'abondance énergétique bien
évidemment quand vous voyez cette
évolution qui est quasi hyperbolique
on peut se poser à raisonnablement la
question de savoir si ça va durer très
longtemps s'est pas complètement sûr
c'est à dire je ne suis pas complètement
persuadé que le point d'équilibré de la
population humaine sur terre sur
quelques siècles ou quelques milliers
d'années ça soit 8 milliards d'individus
frais semblablement beaucoup plus
l'accent
si je fais énergie disponible par
personne x nombre de personnes j'arrive
à cette courbe en ce qui concerne enfin
ce graphique en ce qui concerne
l'énergie qu'on utilise dans le monde à
nouveau ça c'est le petit machin dont on
parle dans la presse
et ça c'est la réalité de ce qui se
passe si on parle non pas quantité mais
variations voilà un petit calcul que je
me suis amusé à faire j'ai représenté
ici sur ce graphique non pas la quantité
d'énergie qu'on utilise par nrj mais la
manière dont chaque énergie avait varié
entre 2000 et 2010 8 alors entre 2000 et
2010 8 qu'est ce qui se passe
il se passe des choses une qui va vous
concerne et vous une qui concerne
l'autre 1 il se passe ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler l'essor des nerfs d'accord
l'essor des énergies renouvelables et 2
un autre truc qui est l'essor de
l'informatique alors un premier constat
que vous pouvez facilement faire c'est
si l'essor de l'informatique avait
permis de faire baisser ces trois termes
là qui sont les termes qui nous
enquiquine ça se verrait pour
qu'aujourd'hui ils baissent pas du tout
en fait les trois énergies qui ont le
plus augmenté sur les 15 dernières fois
sur les 20 dernières années c'est les
énergies fossiles
donc aujourd'hui l'idée qu'on a
dématérialisé l'économie en mettant de
l'informatique partout il ya une
première manière très simple de voir que
c'est pas vrai c'est que les énergies
fossiles ont continué à augmenter encore
plus vite qu'avant la deuxième chose que
vous voyez c'est que c'est bien les
énergies fossiles qui augmentait le plus
considérablement plus que le solaire
l'éolien ou même l'hydroélectricité qui
est le premier terme d'augmentation des
énergies renouvelables sur cette période
donc c'est pas parce que l'on cause que
l'on fait c'est pas parce qu'on se
raconte à nous mêmes que il se passe des
choses que c'est vraiment ça qui se
passe aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est
que on est très exactement sur la même
trajectoire que avant qu'on commence à
parler du changement climatique et avant
qu'on dise que l'informatique
dématérialisée tout ça évolue de manière
extrêmement continue
vous avez ici l'évolution de la
production électrique dans le monde
alors l'évolution de la production
électrique dans le monde la jouent leur
présente simplement depuis 1985 en 1945
en 1945 la consommation électrique
mondiale était du même ordre de grandeur
que la production électrique française
aujourd'hui consommation électrique
mondiale en 1945 était du même ordre de
grandeur que la production électrique
française aujourd'hui
donc vous êtes né et même moi je suis né
dans un monde dans lequel l'électricité
est un truc ordinaire il faut savoir que
c'est extrêmement récents dans
l'histoire des hommes et les femmes
extrêmement récents ce que vous voyez
sur ce graphique c'est que pour le
moment la quantité la production
électrique augmente fortement si je vous
avais masqué l'axé des abscisses ici en
vous disant grâce au numérique on est
devenu plus efficace
je vous aurais mis au défi de me dire de
quand date le début du numérique sur ce
graphique les ya un an personne n'aurait
trouvé
vous ne voyez aucune inflexion dans la
quantité d'électricité consommée dans le
monde à cause du numérique 0 que vous
voyez pas que ça râle ça ralentit rien
du tout ça a évolué exactement comme
avant
40% de la production électrique mondiale
est faite avec du charbon
le charbon donc comme je vous le disais
on le brûle brûle est un hydrocarbure
cet oxyde et d'hydrogène et du carbone
donc ça fait du co2 y'a pas moyen d'y
échapper
donc un kilo de un kilowattheure
électrique au charbon ça vous fait un
kilo de co2 après vous avez à peu près
25% de la production mondiale qui est
faite avec du gaz alors le gaz a beau
être naturel c'est génial c'est le gaz
naturel donc ça peut pas faire de mal
en fait non le gaz naturel est une
énergie fossile comme les autres
énergies c'est la moins carboné t3 mais
vous savez les génies du marketing ont
oublié de s'occuper du cas du charbon et
du pétrole parce qu'ils auraient pu dire
il aurait pu appeler le pétrole de
pétrole naturel ce qui est parfaitement
le 40 pétrole est naturel et il aurait
pu dire du charbon naturel et c'est
parfaitement le car le charbon est
naturelle puis on aurait eu des mines de
cuivre naturel de bauxite naturel de
diamants naturel tout ce qu'on trouve
dans la nature et naturel en fait nous
n'utilisons que des ressources
naturelles
puisque tout ce qu'on utilise se trouve
dans la nature à nouveau tales merlin
l'enchanteur nous ne faisons pas
apparaître de nouveaux éléments dans le
tableau de mendeleïev avec une baguette
magique
ils se trouvent tous dans la nature sont
déjà là donc le gaz 25% de la production
électrique mondiale et 400 grammes de
co2 par kilowattheure il ya du pétrole
un peu pas beaucoup alors pas beaucoup
parce que ça vaut cher mais il y en a
quand même un peu parce qu'il ya des
espèces de moteurs d'avions qui
s'appelle les turbines à combustion
qu'on utilise dans les réseaux
électriques pour avoir de la puissance
disponible de façon quasi instantanée
alors c'est un mauvais rendement ce
voisin n'a pas beaucoup ça coûte très
cher mais on en a quand même un peu
après les deux grands modes décarbonés
que nous avons sur terre sont d'abord
l'hydroélectricité alors il ya quand
même un peu de co2 qu'il faut faire le
barrage donc il faut faire du ciment et
d'acier et ça ça fait du co2 et puis le
nucléaire il ya aussi un peu de co2
parce que il faut aller chercher du
radium le transforme et c'est alors dans
le cadre du barrage en a pas beaucoup
parce qu'une fois que l'eau une fois que
le barrage est construit ballot qui te
l'eau qui passe ça et mes pas et en ce
qui concerne le nucléaire une fois que
la centrale est construite et que
l'uranium est allégé dans l'ami afin
qu'on a cherché l'uranium dans la mine
le reste n'émet pas de co2 et il faut
des petites quantités de matière pour
libérer les grandes quantités d'énergie
en ce qui concerne le nucléaire et pour
vous qui avez fait des études brillantes
vous allez tout de suite comprendre
quand vous avez une réaction chimique
c'est à dire un réarrangement de la
couche électronique l'énergie mise en
jeu et typiquement de quelques électrons
volts par atome
quand vous avez un réarrangement d'une
du noyau nucléiques et bien par exemple
une fission de l'uranium l'énergie mise
en jeu et typiquement de 200 millions
d'électronvolts par atome d'accord donc
quelques électrons volts pour une
réaction chimique quelques milles
quelques centaines de millions
d'électron volts pour une réaction
nucléaire
ce qui veut dire que la quantité de
matières qu'il faut manipuler pour
obtenir de l'énergie nucléaire est
considérablement inférieure à la
quantité de matières qu'il faut
manipuler pour obtenir la même énergie
par voie chimique
c'est à dire par exemple une combustion
et donc comme le nucléaire manipule des
très petites quantités de matière ça
veut dire que même si la manipulation
d'un kilo de matière et met beaucoup de
co2 ramené au kilowattheure produit en
sortie de centrales ça vous fait des
émissions qui sont très faibles
c'est juste pour cette raison physique
que les émissions sont pas élevés et
enfin là vous avez les nouvelles
énergies renouvelables qui sont pas d
énergie zéro carbone qui ne sont pas d
énergie zéro carbone parce que vous avez
aussi des combustibles fossiles parce
que si les énergies semblables pardon le
collecteur lui ne l'est pas une éolienne
ces dix à vingt métaux un panneau
photovoltaïque ses vins métaux donc il
faut aller les chercher avec des engins
de mines faut aller chercher de minerais
faut faire la métallurgie amont pour
faire de la chimie avons offert des
transports intermédiaire tout ça émet du
co2 donc vous avez aussi du co2 dans les
énergies renouvelables
vous en avez plus ou moins que dans les
alternatives mais vous en avez donc à
chaque fois faut compter donc là ce que
je suis en train de vous dire c'est que
il ya un job pour les ingénieurs dans
cette affaire qui est deux comtés
d'abord et d'avoir une conclusion
ensuite alors le gros problème c'est que
vos chefs qui s'appelle des politiques
ils font la verse d'abord ils ont une
conclusion et ensuite éventuellement ils
comptent pas souvent le moins possible
des slogans c'est quand même beaucoup
plus facile à manipuler et soit dit en
passant quand vous êtes patron d'une
grande entreprise
vous êtes aussi très tenté par les
slogans beaucoup plus faciles à
manipuler que de changer les business
models donc le les énergies
renouvelables c'est pas zéro carbone
et si je prends des batteries pour aller
derrière les batteries c'est de la
métallurgie 1
vous savez que dans une batterie vous
avez toujours besoin de métal et dont il
a raison pour laquelle c'est le lithium
qui est préféré aujourd'hui c'est parce
que le lithium et le plus léger des
métaux disponibles sur terre et comme
l'énergie d'ionisation c'est quelques
électrons volts par atome quel que soit
le poids de la tome m'a plu votre atome
de métal et léger plus vous pouvez
mettre une grande quantité d'énergie par
unité de poids donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on va chercher du lithium pour
faire des batteries performantes et on
ne fera rien de mieux que la métallurgie
du lithium
tant qu'on fait des batteries
électrochimique ça c'est pour cette
raison
donc la batterie c'est de la métallurgie
et donc vous avez aussi du co2 dans la
fabrication de la batterie par exemple
une voiture électrique la fabrication de
la voiture donc l'acier réduction du
minerai de fer ça fait du co2 plastique
pétrochimie ça fait du co2 etc
la voiture elle même c'est autant
d'émissions que la batterie ou
inversement la batterie de la voiture
c'est autant d'émissions que la queue
que la voiture que le reste de la
voiture
donc ce n'est pas complètement
négligeable de fabriquer une batterie ça
peut être intéressant quand même à une
voiture électrique en france c'est plus
intéressant qu'une voiture à pétrole de
moitié à peu près mais c'est pas héros
donc dès que vous voyez dans un titre
d'article de presse c'est zéro co2 parce
que sais je sais pas quoi renouvelables
achats etc électrique
c'est faux c'est toujours faux ça peut
être peu s'est jamais 0 alors dans cette
histoire je vais en revenir à ma facture
du début une facture comme vous le savez
ça s'exprime en euros ou en dollars
enfin en mode est donc une facture ça
s'exprime avec un prix un prix ça
résulte d'un raisonnement économique la
formation des prix c'est quelque chose
qui vient d'un raisonnement économique
et dans le raisonnement économique qu'on
enseigne encore aujourd'hui aux chères
têtes blondes ou brunes que vous êtes et
qu'on m'a enseignées quand j'avais votre
âge
eh bien il ya un postulat de départ qui
est un non dit on ne vous le dit pas il
est implicite dans ce qu'on vous dit
mais il n'est jamais explicite donc là
je voulais explicite le postulat de
départ c'est que la nature est gratuite
alors vous allez me dire la nature est
gratuite ça se discute ça se discute
parce que la totalité du pib mondial
aujourd'hui dépend du fait qu'il y ait
20 % d'oxygène dans leur si demain matin
je supprime 20% d'oxygène dans l'air que
parfaitement gratuit que devient le pib
mondial 0 ouais d'accord
si je supprime une atmosphère respirable
sur terre il ya plus d'hommes parce
qu'on meurt tous et donc à plus de pib
donc le fait que les ressources
naturelles soient gratuites ne veut pas
dire qu'elles ne sont pas indispensables
donc on a fait 1 1 une théorie et qui a
été explicitement décrite par cet homme
là et tous les gens sont ses
contemporains qui dit que si on fait ça
ça vaut zéro ce qu'à partir du moment où
la nature est gratuite
entamé un actif qui vaut 0 1 0 0
d'accord avec moi qu'une partie des
héros c'est toujours 0
c'est le grand mérite des éléments
absorbant de l'élément absolument de la
multiplication donc on ne verra pas
venir par les prix les problèmes que on
s'apprête à avoir avec un défaut de
ressources naturelles parce que les
ressources naturelles sont pas dans la
formation des prix
si j les choses un peu autrement le
système productif tel qu'on le
schématise aujourd'hui c'est que vous
avez deux agents productifs qui sont le
capital et le travail
et grâce à ça le supermarché est rempli
mais d'accord capital et travail on
remplit supermarché
alors ce que dira l'ingénieur s'il
regarde ça d'un tout petit peu dire d'un
tout petit peu près 10 rabat ces
produits sont faits d'éléments et 92
éléments du tableau de mendeleïev ils
sortent d'où là dedans là parce que
c'est pas l'ouvrier qui sépare d'une
partie de son corps comme ça qu'on
obtient ce qui constitue les produits et
sauf erreur de ma part c'est paris qui
sortent pas le minerai de cuivre sont
pas non plus des billets de banque
donc l'ingénieur il va dire ouais très
bien pour qu'on ait des produits il faut
qu'on ait les ressources qu'on va
pouvoir transformer pour faire ces
produits et ça vaut même pour les
services
nous sommes ici dans un établissement de
service un établissement d'enseignement
cet établissement ne fonctionne que
parce qu'il ya des substrats physique
vous n'êtes pas assis sur de l'air vous
êtes assis sur les chaises et des bancs
très inconfortable du reste en bois vous
avez devant vous des pupitres tout aussi
inconfortable en bois ce bâtiment a été
fait avec du carbonate de calcium
calciné ça s'appelle du ciment plus des
granulats plus du minerai de fer
transformée ça s'appelle de l'acier plus
tout un tas de produits dérivés du
pétrole c'est les plastiques et toutes
les fiches de synthèse plus un peu de
sable et de carbonate de soude ça
s'appelle du vert plus tôt fin bref tous
les éléments du tableau de mendeleïev
sont dans cette salle touche corps donc
on est allé les chercher dans la nature
on les a transformés c'est ça qui permet
de faire un service d'enseignement faire
un service d'enseignement au milieu du
vide intersidéral c'est plus compliqué
dont tous les produits tous les services
que nous avons aujourd'hui à d'autres
dispositions ont tous été fait avec des
ressources naturelles que nous avons
transformé et si on les a transformés
c'est qu'il ya eu du travail donc je
vais en revenir à ce que je disais tout
à l'heure le travail c'est une
transformation ça se mesure donc en
énergie et cette transformation avec le
petit raisonnement je vous ai fait tout
à l'heure elle est faite à hauteur de 1
par nos carcasse et à hauteur de 200 par
le parc mondial de machines donc là vous
voyez apparaître deux facteurs limitants
supplémentaire de l'économie qui sont le
fait qu'on ait les machines et l'énergie
pour les faire fonctionner et le fait
qu'on ait les ressources naturelles
suffit pas d'avoir des banquiers
compréhensif et des gens qui se lèvent
le matin pour aller bosser
et soit dit en passant ce que vous voyez
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya un excès de
gens qui aimeraient bien se lever le
matin pour aller bosser ça s'appelle des
chômeurs et il ya un excès de capital
puisqu'à des bulles spéculatives partout
et les tableaux complets d'argent dont
il a pas quoi faire
donc ce qui était dans la théorie
économique classique les deux facteurs
limitants d'autres activités sont en
fait aujourd'hui si vous regardez bien
dans le monde qui nous entoure les deux
facteurs excédentaire et le fait que la
croissance ne repartent pas ne vient pas
du défaut de ces deux facteurs qui en a
trop donc ça vient nécessairement d'une
limite qui s'applique ailleurs et en
fait cette limite
elle vient des deux facteurs
supplémentaires que je viens d'évoquer
alors il ya aussi du capital dans ce
schéma le capital c'est juste une partie
de la production qui se détruit pas
quand on s'en sert et qu'on garde pour
augmenter la production future
c'est juste ça mais ça se fait de la
même manière
et donc ce que vous comprenez facilement
en regardant ce graphique c'est que si
on est privé d'énergie une partie des
machines ne fonctionnera pas et une
partie des pros de la production n'aura
pas lieu
alors je prends un exemple idiot demain
matin je supprime la moitié du pétrole
disponible pour les camions en france la
moitié des clients peuvent pas être
livré la moitié des usines peuvent pas
être livré la moitié des entrepôts
peuvent pas être approvisionnés la
moitié des marchandises sont pas livré
la moitié des produits agricoles
n'arrive pas dans paris donc soit dit en
passant vous allez avoir un petit sujet
moi aussi etc
vous comprendrez bien la machine se
grippe et ce même si vous avez plein de
conducteurs de camions qui sont pas
prêts à se lever tôt le matin et même si
vous n'avez pas de banquiers qui sont
prêts à financer des camions
la machine se grippe c'est aussi bête
que ça
et si vous avez un défaut de ressources
eh bien on aura exactement le même
problème
par exemple si vous avez un défaut de
carrière mais plein d'énergie dans les
tractopelles et bien vous aurez du mal à
finir le grand paris parce qu'il aura
pas les matériaux de construction pour
finir le grand paris ce que je vous dis
des produits de l'esprit soit dit en
passant il ya un petit stress sur les
matériaux de construction
en ce qui concerne le grand prix ce lien
direct entre l'énergie
alors ce que vous voyez pardon aussi sur
ce graphique c'est que tant qu'il n'y a
pas de facteur limitant qui s'applique
ni à la population ni aux machines ni
aux ressources et bien vous avez
l'élément dominant du système c'est le
parc de machines c'est pas les hommes
c'est les hommes sont là que pour
piloter les machines c'est pas l'élément
l'évidence on voit ici un graphique qui
vous donne cette évolution en deux temps
il est daté de la naissance de monsieur
jésus-christ et il reproduit la
production économique mondiale donc la
production mondiale depuis la naissance
de monsieur jésus-christ alors ce que
vous voyez c'est que jusqu'au bas
moyen-âge
il n'y a pas de croissance c'est à dire
que la production annuelle est à peu
près égale à la production de l'année
qui précédait pourquoi parce que vous
n'avez pas de machine pour vous aider à
cette époque-là pas beaucoup vous avez
quelques moulins enfin pas beaucoup et
vous n'avez quelques bateaux à voile
mais c'est quand même très très mineur
par rapport à l'essentiel de la
population est par ailleurs la
population ne croit pas ou ne crois pas
beaucoup parce que elle croit puis vous
avez une paix celle des crop et c'est
donc la population mondiale est à peu
près stable
elle croit un peu mettre à peu près
stable et donc tout ça n'augmente
quasiment pas si je vais jusqu'à la
veille de la révolution industrielle
or cette semaine a augmenté un peu plus
vite vous avez quand même une proto
révolution industrielle au moyen-âge qui
augmente un peu tout ça mais c'est
surtout à partir de la révolution
industrielle c'est à dire de la
découverte des nouveaux convertisseurs
qui mangent du pétrole du gaz et du
charbon que alors là ça se met à être à
l'oubli comme un bric à brac et que vous
avez l'économie qui se met à croître de
manière très rapide
et alors maintenant vous avez les
économistes qui ont inventé un truc que
je trouve très drôle qui s'appelle la
croissance structurelle long terme
d'accor dont une sur une planète qui ne
dépassera pas les treize mille
kilomètres de diamètre était le cas il
ya deux siècles ce sera le cas dans 4
et nous avons une croissance
structurelle de long terme évidemment
qu'on a pas de croissance structurelle
de long terme
ce truc là dure aussi longtemps qu'aucun
facteur de production des limites en
point juste ça si je fais un zoom sur la
période récente
vous voyez que là on a le meilleur
modèle que je connaisse en ce qui
concerne la la macroéconomie qui
s'appelle une droite et qui consiste à
dire quelque chose de très bête
je regarde la quantité totale d'énergie
que le monde utilisent c'est à dire le
parc total de machines que le monde
utilisent et j'ai la production
économique qui en résulte
dit autrement aujourd'hui le premier
facteur limitant de la production
s'appelle l'énergie sept premiers et ça
explique pourquoi j'ai pas le temps de
vous montrer les courbes aujourd'hui
mais ça explique pourquoi dans tous les
pays qui depuis que je m'intéresse à ce
sujet se sont retrouvés en défaut
d'approvisionnement énergétique sans
l'avoir voulu
vous avez des problèmes économiques qui
se développe rapidement et notamment ça
concerne toute l'europe du sud depuis
2006 pour ceux que ça intéresse c'est
sur mon site personnel
un article qui s'appelle l'italie et
l'énergie un cas d'école à les regarder
et vous verrez que les troubles
politiques que nous avons aujourd'hui en
italie sont une conséquence directe du
stress sur l'approvisionnement pétrolier
que ce pays a commencé à connaître après
2006 alors nous ça nous pend au nez
aussi bien c'est pas pour dans deux cent
cinquante trois ans
si je regarde n'ont pas eu les valeurs
absolues mais les variations j'obtiens
quelque chose qui me confirme ce lien
c'est à dire qu'ici envers vous avez la
variation de la quantité d'énergie
disponible dans le monde c'est-à-dire du
parc de machines en fonctionnement et en
bleu vous avez la variation de la
production économique mondiale
et vous voyez que c'est exactement de la
même manière donc la production
économique mondiale
c'est la quantité de machines qui
fonctionnent et la voici le drame des
négociations climat comme l'essentiel de
cette énergie et fossiles et qu'elle est
toujours aussi fossiles au cours du
temps et bien le pib mondial est une
fonction linéaire des émissions de co2
mondiales
alors je vais vous le dire autrement si
on veut être sérieux sur le climat
aujourd'hui qui dans cette salle a signé
le manifeste étudiants pour un réveil
écologique et ben vous ne le savez pas
mais vous vous le savez peut-être j'en
sais rien mais quelque part vous avez
réclamé un truc qui s'appelle la
décroissance
parce que on ne fera pas baisser les
émissions de co2 à la bonne vitesse sans
contracter le système économique
on n'y arrivera pas alors il va se
contracter toute façon un jour puisque
les combustibles fossiles sont pas
éternelles je vous en parlais dans pas
longtemps mais on n'arrivera pas à le
faire volontairement à la bonne vitesse
dans un contexte de croissance
économique
ou plus exactement si on cherche
également la croissance économique c'est
juste pas possible
alors une fois qu'on sait ça commence le
vrai grattage de tête
qu'est ce que je fais ah j'aurais pas
fromage et dessert qu'est ce que je
choisis et le vrai débat il est là c'est
à dire que on peut très bien dire bah on
s'en fout du client choisit et en fait
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire en
ce moment on choisit la croissance tant
que ça passe et puis dans un climat on
verra plus tard
mais c'est clairement le choix entre les
deux aujourd'hui il épouse et il n'est
pas posée parce que j'ai envie d'être
désagréable ou parce que je suis un
décroissante east force d où c'est
pourquoi il est posée parce que quand
vous voyez la physique sous jacente à
notre activité productive
vous comprenez que ça va être très très
compliqué de conjuguer à la fois la
baisse des émissions de co2 et le
maintien des flux productif donc
l'histoire que nous vivons depuis
maintenant deux siècles se peut se
résumer de la manière suivante
mère-nature à former sous le sol en
quelques dizaines à quelques centaines
de millions d'années parce que c'est à
peu près le temps que ça prend à partir
de résidus de vie ancienne du plancton
et des microalgues quelque chose qui
s'appelle des combustibles fossiles et
ses combustibles fossiles comme toutes
les ressources naturelles sur terre sont
gratuites vous allez dire le pétrole est
pas du tout gratuit il coûte très cher à
la pompe et c'est terence ici le pétrole
est gratuit le vent est gratuit qui dans
cette salle à payer quoi que ce soit
pour que le vent se forment personnes
qui dans cette salle à payer quoi que ce
soit pour que le pétrole se forment la
personne non plus donc le pétrole est
tout à fait gratuit ce qui est payant
c'est d'aller le chercher
donc c'est soit de payer les gens qui
sont assis dessus pour qu'ils acceptent
sans défaire soin de leur passé sur le
corps avec des chars et des avions on a
fait les deux et ensuite c'est de
prendre des ingénieurs d'ici ou
d'ailleurs pour faire les tuyaux les
pompes etc et faire les shadoks est allé
chercher le pétrole
voilà ça c'est payant mais le fait que
le pétrole existe c'est gratuit c'est
quand tu y a qu'à se baisser pour aller
le ramasser
donc ce pétrole gratuit qui peut donner
une réaction exothermique qui s'appelle
la combustion a permis de mettre en jeu
un parc de machines qui a permis de
transformer tout le reste manière
accélérée alors pétrole gaz charbon elle
reste un et ça a permis de faire tous
les objets qui nous entourent et
l'augmentation de la productivité du
travail qui en résulte c'est à dire le
fait que les machines bosse à notre
place ça a libéré une quantité infinie
de temps libre pour les hommes que nous
avons plus affectés aux études longues
donc vous êtes les enfants comme je
l'étais avant vous de l'énergie
abondante sinon je le répète passeriez
vos journées comme moi à ramasser des
patates la raison pour laquelle vous
êtes dans cet amphi c'est parce qu'on
est drogué à l'énergie donc on a affecté
ce temps libre aux études longues à la
retraite aux 35 heures aux congés payés
au week-end et c'est tout ça c'est une
affectation du temps libre qui a été
dégagée par le fait qu'on n'est plus
obligé de travailler puisque c'est les
machines qui bossent en place
on a une manière de conter cette
affaire-là
c'est une des manières avec des héros
s'appelle le pib est alors vous
comprenez bien qu'on a donc de goulets
d'étranglement dans cette histoire on
n'a plus que ça mais on a au moins deux
le premier goulets d'étranglement c'est
le sous produit de cette combustion qui
s'appelle du gaz carbonique va résider
très longtemps dans l'atmosphère je vais
y revenir un peu plus tard et ça
occasionne une modification des échanges
énergétiques entre l'espace et la
surface planétaire qui s'appelle le
changement climatique et la question
c'est combien de temps est-ce qu'on peut
jouer à ce petit jeu là avant que le
résultat de l'expérience ne devienne
très désagréable mais il ya une deuxième
question qui est là aussi totalement
inexistante dans le débat public
français qui est combien de temps est-ce
que mon activité de shadocks là elle
dure
sachant que mon stock de départ ça dure
et de reconstitutions ses 50 à 400
millions d'années
autrement dit plus l'infini aux échelles
de temps qui nous intéresse
or il se trouve pour parler du deuxième
problème que je pourrais vous donner à
démontrer un petit théorème de maths que
je sais encore démontré qui est que
quand vous avez une extraction d'un
stock initial qui est donnée une fois
pour toutes
vous êtes très facilement capable de
démontrer par l'absurde
alors deux choses évidentes puis une qui
l'est moins la première chose évidente
que vous savez démontrer c'est que on ne
peut pas avoir une extraction annuel
indéfiniment croissante en provenance de
stoke qui n'ont le stock est infinie on
ne peut même pas avoir une extraction
annuel indéfiniment constante en
provenance de ce stock
sinon le stock est infinie en fait on ne
peut rien à voir d'autre qu'une fonction
d'extraction qui est nul a moins la plus
et moins l'infini et qui passe par un
maximum absolu entre les deux voilà ça
se démontre
je le sais encore faire la démonstration
ce qui veut dire que en ce qui concerne
toute ressource minérale ou fossile
disponible dans la croûte terrestre et
dont l'inventaire de départ est donné
une fois pour toutes on peut ne pas bien
le connaître c'est à dire on peut ne pas
savoir exactement combien de pétrole
dans la croûte terrestre
il suffit de savoir que ya besoin de 100
millions d'années en ordre de grandeur
pour que ça soit constitue aimons
théorème est valable à ce moment je sais
qu'à un moment il y aura un maximum à
l'extraction annuel qui s'appelle le
piquet et ça vaut aussi pour le minerai
de cuivre pour la bauxite pour le cobalt
pour le dit qu'elle pour le tungstène
pour le vanadium pour le chrome pour le
platine pour l'or pour l'argent pour le
zirconium en fait n'importe lequel des
éléments qui est disponible dans la
croûte terrestre vous avez un pic à son
extraction
alors évidemment le bon débat c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il provoquait ce qu'a
vraiment tout ça c'est des bons débats
mais le fait qu'il en est un c'est un
théorème de bahts
donc vous pouvez pas invalidé les
théorèmes de maths normalement c'est
justement fait les théorèmes pour être
toujours valable dans les conditions
initiales dans des conditions initiales
qui sont les mêmes alors voilà un autre
élément qui est totalement passée sous
silence dans la presse française
en fait il se trouve que pour tout ce
qui n'est pas le pétrole de roche mère
aux états unis qu'on appelle dans le
débat public français du shale oil ou du
pétrole de schiste
tout ça c'est pareil et les sables
bitumineux canadiens savent et les trucs
qui s'exploitent dans des mines à ciel
ouvert là au canada en commençant par
couper les arbres c'est du sable mélangé
à du bitume qu'on finit par transformer
en hydrocarbures liquides et bien si
j'exclus ces deux compartiments là c'est
à dire le pétrole de schiste et les
sables bitumineux tout le reste de la
production pétrolière mondiale est
passée par un maximum en 2008 et décline
depuis qu'ils en avaient entendu parler
beaucoup mieux renseigné que la moyenne
de la population française et il ya
cette main qui sont levés personne n'en
a jamais entendu parler d'accord donc je
sais pas dans le journal non plus tu as
fait c'est documenté il suffit d'aller
regarder les statistiques juste pas dans
le journal alors vous allez me dire mais
oui mais si le pétrole devient plus rare
on devrait se rendre compte au travers
du prix alors deuxième chose très
désagréable il n'ya pas d'élasticité
prix volumes en ce qui concerne le
pétrole à long terme dit autrement ce
qu'on vous apprend en économie qui est
si y en a moins le prix monte
indéfiniment c'est faux
c'est faux c'est faux il suffit de
regarder la courbe c'est faux si c'était
vrai cette histoire
vous avez ici la quantité de pétrole qui
est consommée chaque année et tout passe
par le marché donc tout est achetée est
ici le prix du baril est bien six mois y
en a plus c'est cher et plus y en a
moins c'est cher
les prix devraient être organisées par
les points ici devrait être organisé le
nom d'un le long d'un nuage qui
ressemble à ça un plus haut d'un arbre
assez cher moi y en a plus c'est cher ce
que vous voyez c'est que la relation
prix volume n'est absolument pas celle
là si je regarde sur un siècle
je peux avoir une production qui varient
énormément avec un prix qui reste stable
un prix qui varie énormément avec une
production qui reste quasi stable et
rebelote dans les deux cas de figure il
n'y a pas ce avec une élasticité ces
objectifs un sas et directif là il n'y a
pas de relation bij et ctive prix
volumes en ce qui concerne le pétrole ni
soit dit en passant en ce qui concerne
aucune ressource naturelle donc l'idée
qu'on va voir arriver la rareté physique
par une hausse indéfinie du prix ça ne
marche pas alors je pourrais vous
expliquer c'est un peu long je pourrais
vous expliquer pourquoi c'est
parfaitement normal que ça ne marche pas
deuxième chose qui marche pas le fait
que quand le prix du pétrole augmente
c'est mauvais pour le pib mondial
non c'est pas vrai
ici vous avez un graphique dans lequel
là vous avez le prix du baril et en
ordonnée vous avez le pib mondial c'est
pareil si quand le prix augmente c'est
mauvais pour le pib
quand je vais vers la droite les points
ici devrait être plus bas que quand je
suis à gauche
en fait vous voyez qu'il ya zéro alors
là ça part de 1960 et l'asse 2018
et vous voyez qu'il ya strictement aucun
lien le pib peut augmenter avec un prix
du baril qui baisse avec un prix du
baril qui monte avec un prix du baril
qui baisse avec un prix du baril qui
monte est complètement est la raison
pour à cela c'est tout simplement que la
hausse du prix du pétrole c'est un
simple transfert de revenus c'est à dire
que nous on en a moins
et l'échec arabes en ont plus juste sans
quoi et donc ils le dépensent puis voilà
par contre le volume 1 ça marche très
bien
vous avez ici deux courbes à nouveau la
courbe rouge vous représente la
variation de la production mondiale de
pétrole
c'est une moyenne lissée sur trois ans
et la courbe bleue vous reprendre vos
représente la variation du pib par
personne dans le monde
c'est aussi une courbe lycée sur trois
ans et bien ce que vous voyez c'est que
depuis ce qu'on appelle les chocs
pétroliers ça dit quelque chose à
quelqu'un les chocs pétroliers ici ce
que vous êtes un peu jeune un vrai choc
pétrolier ces 74 et 79
le prix du pétrole qui explose parce que
la production de pétrole qui augmentait
de 8 à 9% par an art est d'augmenter en
euro mais a augmenté 1 % par an elle
continue à augmenter depuis mais je veux
dire beaucoup plus doucement ça a
provoqué un choc de prix absolument
monstrueux est l'une des raisons à cela
c'est le pic de production du pétrole
conventionnel aux états unis donc ce que
vous voyez c'est que depuis cette époque
là où on a fait des gros efforts pour
être plus efficace dans le pétrole les
deux courbes sont parfaitement ajusté
est en fait la courbe rouge c'est à dire
la variation de la production de pétrole
précède la courbe bleue c'est à dire la
variation du pib par personne donc le
meilleur indicateur avancé que je
connaisse sur ce que sera le pib de
l'année prochaine c'est la quantité de
pétrole qui va sortir des puits d'année
prochaine
c'est le meilleur indicateur que je
connaisse
et quand il n'y a pas de relation prix
volume ça ne vous dit pas quel sera le
prix du pétrole qui toute façon on s'en
fou pour le pib mondial
alors comment évolue la production de
pétrole dans le monde
c'est part ça je vais finir vous avez
ici une courbe que j'ai obtenus en
prenant la quantité de pétrole et de
condensat qui sont des pétrole léger qui
viennent avec le gaz produites dans le
monde depuis 1994
et c'est dans le monde hors états unis
et bien ce que vous voyez c'est que la
production de pétrole dans le monde hors
états unis n'augmente plus depuis 2005
c'est ça qui a directement déclenché la
crise économique qu'on a coutume de
retenir aujourd'hui sous le nom de crise
des subprimes en fait la crise des
subprimes démarre par une décélération
du pib aux etats unis en 2006 2007 une
décélération un retournement des prix de
l'immobilier et comme les états unis où
un système vachement intelligent où les
gens s'endettent à hauteur de la valeur
de leur maison
super intelligent pas volatile pour un
sou dans nom est bien quand les prix de
l'immobilier se retourne tout le monde
devient insolvable traître est vachement
sympa comme système et à ce moment
évidemment tous les actifs qui avait été
gagé sur les emprunts immobiliers
notamment les subprimes se casse la
gueule mais la vraie raison de départs
c'est un retournement des prix de
l'immobilier liée à un ralentissement
économique lui-même lié à ce que je suis
en train de vous montrer
chronologiquement quand vous regardez
c'est très clair que c'est dans ce sens
là que ça se passe
ce qui veut dire que toute la hausse de
la production mondiale de pétrole qu'on
a connus depuis 2005 en l'occurrence
depuis 2010 parce qu'entre 2005 et 2010
et rester flat dans le monde vient du
pétrole de schiste aux états unis le
moment où la production de pétrole de
schiste aux états unis se met à se
casser la gueule parce que ça finira
fatalement par arriver dans un an dans
trois ans dans cinq ans dans dix ans
dans 20 ans
fatalement ça finira par arriver à ce
moment là la production dans le monde se
retourne et on a de nouveau une grosse
crise économique
mécaniquement ça sera marc chouarain
c'est bien alors à côté de ça on a un
deuxième sujet qui est le climat on
vient dire non puis à problème est réglé
nous avons les accords de paris donc en
monsieur fabius qui transformée en
commissaire priseur pour l'occasion
s'agite son grand marteau du commissaire
priseur le tape sur la table sous le
regard et d'amour et de pardon sous le
regard ravi de christina figueres tard à
gauche et déclare l'accord de paris
adopté
meirieu donc le problème du changement
climatique est réglé alors ça c'est
peut-être vrai dans les discours on va
de nouveau s'intéresser à quelques faits
vous avez ici la concentration
atmosphérique en co2 en gaz carbonique
depuis 1995 alors cette concentration
atmosphérique on a coutume de l'exprimer
non pas en pourcentage parce qu'à part
assez de co2 dans l'atmosphère pour que
ça fasse 1 % ça fait beaucoup moins de
1%
on exprime sa en partie par million en
millionième est donc 100 millionième
c'est donc 0 0 1% mais on préfère et vie
écrire des pmp toqués faire des 0-0 mach
1 %
ce que vous voyez c'est que en 1995
la quantité de co2 dans l'atmosphère est
alors de 360 parties par million et 1995
est évidemment une année de grands
succès pour les négociations
internationales sur le climat puisque
c'est l'année où la convention climat
qui a été discuté à rioz sommet de la
terre en 1992 entre en vigueur après
avoir été ratifié par tous les pays de
la planète et donc on fait une
grand-messe 1995 soit dit en passant est
ce que vous savez où était hébergé cette
grand-messe en 1995 dans quel pays et
quel était le ministre de
l'environnement du pays à l'époque alors
la réponse est que c'était en allemagne
et que le ministre de l'environnement de
l'époque s'appelait hong et la merkel
donc 1995 comme un grand grand grand
succès puisque enfin les pays sont
d'accord pour faire ce qu'il faut pour
que le changement climatique soit pas
trop méchant alors vous voyez
l'évolution que ça a eu sur la
concentration en co2 derrière arrivent
kyoto qui est un grand succès puisque
c'est la première année où on décide
d'avoir un engagement quantifié de
réduction des pays occidentaux
alors vous voyez l'effet que ça a eu sur
la concentration derrière après arrive
copenhague qui est un énorme échec
vous voyez les faits que sa vue sur la
concentration derrière et puis arrive
paris
donc en fait ce que je vous dis à
travers ce petit graphique c'est que la
façon dont la presse va dire qu une coop
est un succès ou un échec est un
non-sujet absolu ce que la presse amp
ans est un non-sujet absolue on s'en
fout complètement
et du reste c'est par la coop que les
choses se passent pourquoi c'est pas à
la coop que les choses se passent pour
deux raisons la première c'est que les
système onusien et la convention climat
est un système onusien
ça se négocie à lui ça se décide à
l'unanimité
alors pour vous expliquer ce que ça veut
dire
imaginons que dans cette salle vous
soyez tous les copropriétaires de la rue
barrault d'accord tous les gens qui sont
dans cette salle sont copropriétaires de
la rue barrault je rentre dans la salle
et je vous dis voilà nous avons une
journée pour nous mettre d'accord à
l'unanimité sur un programme de travaux
d'accord il faut qu'on se mettre
d'accord à l'unanimité sur un programme
de travaux où chaque personne dans la
salle va voter pour un donc le fait que
vous soyez copropriétaire de 1 tantièmes
ou de 10000 tantièmes ça compte pas s'en
fout que quelle que soit la coppola la
part de copropriété que vous avez votre
vote vaut 1
par contre votre effort lui il va être
proportionnelle à votre pourcentage de
détention corps et il faut qu'on vote un
programme de travaux destinés à tout
rénové à l'unanimité je vous pose la
question quelle est la probabilité qu'on
y arrive la réponse est aisée
zéro puisque c'est à l'unanimité
donc n'importe qui peut faire peut
exercer son droit de veto et comme vous
avez tous des intérêts antagonistes en
particulier ceux qui ont une voix en
payant rien ils ont intérêt à pousser à
ce qu'on fasse un énorme programme de
travaux ceux qui ont une voix en payant
tout ils ont intérêt à l'exact inverse
donc vous n'arriverez jamais à vous
mettre d'accord
jamais jamais jamais en plus cette
assemblée n'a pas de syndic
c'est à dire que personne n'arrive avec
un projet de résolution en disant qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
et elle a pas de chef c'est à dire que
personne n'est capable de vous imposer
quoi que ce soit eh ben ça c'est une
assemblée onusienne qui discutent du
climat c'est exactement pareil
c'est à dire que c'est un pays une voix
indépendamment de sa puissance
économique qu'on demande à ceux qui sont
riches de payer pour ceux qui ont pas
beaucoup donc les intérêts sont
divergents
il n'y a pas de résolution quand vous
arrivez c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de
chef qui dit voilà ce que je vous
propose de voter ça n'existe pas chacun
amène sa contribution en disant je
propose que dans le texte et y est ça et
on essaye de faire une mayonnaise
consensuelle de tout ça donc là la
dynamique onusienne c'est que les gens
se mettent d'accord sur ce qu'ils ont
déjà accepté par ailleurs au regard de
leurs opinions domestique ils se mettent
d'accord là dessus
donc c'est un consensus mou et ça ne
peut rien faire d'autre
une coop ne peut rien faire d'autre que
d'entériner des trucs que les gens sont
déjà prêts à faire c'est sale coup donc
faut pas en attendre de miracles faut en
attendre qu'on parle de sujets à elle
c'est très bien ça permet de parler du
changement climatique dans les médias
mais c'est tout ce qu'on peut en
attendre
alors vous allez me dire c'est
dramatique bah oui peut-être je sais pas
en tout cas c'est comme ça
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que la
convention cadre sur le changement
climatique ses 92 sa signature 95 sa
ratification par contre la compréhension
de ce qui se passe au dessus de nos
têtes c'est beaucoup plus ancien que ça
il se trouve que des 1824 donc on va
quasiment pouvoir ont célébré le
centenaire dans pas longtemps enfin
quasiment on va pouvoir ont célébré le
centenaire dans pas longtemps un
français cocorico
monsieur fourier dont vous avez un tout
petit peu entendu parler je pense dit il
ya au dessus de nos têtes dans
l'atmosphère quelque chose qui fait que
les températures au sol sont plus élevés
que si ce quelque chose n'existait pas
encore 1824 un peu plus de dix ans après
et dans le milieu du 19e siècle
il ya deux physiciens qui identifie ce
quelque chose comme étant la vapeur
d'eau et de gaz carbonique donc les deux
principaux gaz à effet de serre de
l'atmosphère sont connus au milieu du
19e siècle à la fin du 19e siècle
il ya monsieur arrhenius quand vous avez
entendu parler que de ces travaux
l'électro lise qui dit il est un petit
camion je pourrais citer s'ennuyer un
soir il n'avait pas le scrabble pas la
télé en bref sa femme devait être parti
chez les copines et donc il fait un
petit calcul de coin table pour
s'occuper et il conclut que si on double
la quantité de co2 dans l'atmosphère les
températures au sol s'élève en moyenne
de 4 degrés donc l'essentiel de ce qu'il
faut comprendre sur la physique du
changement climatique alors ils avaient
tort pour partie de son raisonnement
mais quand même
dans les grandes lignes on avait compris
l'essentiel à la fin du 19e siècle et du
reste l'intuition d'un certain nombre de
scientifiques étaient suffisamment forte
sur le fait qu' il allait se passer
quelque chose pour que dès le milieu du
xxème siècle un homme qui s'appelle
killing démarre un observatoire en
continu de la quantité de co2 présent
dans l'atmosphère
hawaï c'est parce qu'il a mais bien de
surf et pour confirmer l'intuition qu'il
avait qu'il allait constater que ça
augmente est effectivement ce qu'il a
trouvé que ça augmente et alors ça
augmente parce que voilà à quoi
ressemble nos émissions voyez quelque
chose commente depuis un siècle et demi
alors si je vous avais masquer les apsys
rebelote
qui dans cette affaire-là dangereux
parce que les apps si ça on imagine que
je voulais masque qui est capable de me
dater le début de la révolution weiner
et le début de la digitalisation qui
dématérialise tout non c'est compliqué
pas beaucoup
en fait le début de la digitalisation
c'est par là avec en matière de
ralentissement des émissions ça se pose
là et le début du boom hayder c'est par
là aussi vous voyez qu'en matière de
ralentissement la hausse des émissions
ça se pose là aussi donc pour le moment
rien de ce qu'on peut se raconter comme
étant un truc qui va dans le bon sens
n'a d'effet macroscopique et désagréable
à entendre mais c'est comme ça alors ces
émissions d'où viennent elles
elle y est de l'oxydation d'atomes de
carbone qui fait du co2 présent dans les
énergies fossiles carbone charbon
pétrole gaz
elle vient de l'oxydation des atomes de
carbone présent dans la biomasse c'est
la déforestation
elle vient de l'émission de méthane
encore du carbone mais pas dans la même
molécule qui vient de 2,3 processus
essentiellement le méthane qui est émis
lors de l'exploitation des hydrocarbures
la ventilation des mines parce que le
méthane celle crise où les fuites de gaz
etc
les rizières parce que les rizières
c'est un endroit où vous avez de la
décomposition anaérobie qui produit du
méthane et enfin les la fermentation
entérique c'est à dire dans l'estomac ou
dans les estomacs plus exactement des
ruminants
nous sommes 7 milliards et demi d'hommes
sur terre est ce que vous savez combien
il ya de vaches sur terre un milliard et
demi
un milliard et demi de vaches sur terre
c'est à dire que la masse des vaches sur
terre est légèrement supérieure à la
masse des hommes on sache
en 1960 il n'y avait que 1 milliard de
vaches sur terre passé de 1 milliard à 1
milliard et demi et pour rebondir sur
l'actualité récente le pays qui a le
plus augmenté son cheptel depuis 1976
c'est un pays où sa crainte en ce moment
au brésil
le président a multiplié son cheptel par
quatre et évidemment faut nourrir toutes
ses vaches donc il faut faire des
pâturages où il faut faire des cultures
de soja ou les deux ce que vous voyez
c'est que ça augmente
le co2 est un oxyde et vous savez pas ce
que vous avez fait de brillantes études
de chimie que les oxydes sont des
molécules extrêmement stable oxyde sur
des molécules très stable du reste il
faut de l'énergie pour réduire un oxyde
donc si vous mettez un oxyde quelque
part est voulue foutez la paix et bien
il va rien se passer
le fer est présent sous forme d'oxydé à
la surface de la planète depuis des
milliards d'années
c'est stable ce qui veut dire qu'une
fois qu'on a mis le co2 dans
l'atmosphère il n'y a pas de processus
chimiques d'épuration de ce co2 n'y en a
pas il ya deux processus d'épuration du
co2 de l'atmosphère
il ya un processus physiques c'est un
équilibrage de pression partielle entre
l'atmosphère et l'océan fait une
dissolution de co2 dans l'océan et vous
avez un processus physico chimiques
vous avez une réduction en fait avec un
photon c'est la photosynthèse
mais c'est une réduction qui demande de
l'énergie est la conséquence de cette
affaire c'est que si demain matin
j'arrête les émissions le surplus de co2
que nous avons déjà créé notre au dessus
de nos têtes
au bout d'un siècle j'en aurai toujours
40% qui sera là au bout de mille ans
j'en aurai toujours 20% qui sera là et
au bout de dix mille ans j'en aurai
toujours 10% qui sera là donc dit
autrement le surplus de co2 que nous
avons créée au dessus de nos têtes
et pour partie réversible pour partie
réversible 10% et pour une large partie
va demander des durées très très longue
pour s'évacuer de l'atmosphère avec en
plus des phénomènes qui vont handicaper
l'évacuation du co2 de l'atmosphère avec
le temps avec le temps la photosynthèse
va devenir de plus en plus difficile
parce que les écosystèmes terrestres
vont être stressé et avec le temps
l'océan va absorber de moins en moins
bien le co2 parce que l'eau froide 10 ou
mieux le co2 clos chaude n'ont plus
l'eau se réchauffe
- il absorbe bien de co2 donc les deux
puis à co2 aujourd'hui ont tendance à
s'affaiblir avec le temps à cause du
réchauffement climatique
donc le siècle 40% au bout d'un siècle
c'est aujourd'hui si ça se trouve dans
10 ans ou dans vingt ans ça sera pas 40%
au bout d'un siècle 150,60 tout ce que
je suis en train de vous dire c'est que
les conséquences du changement
climatique seront maximales bien après
que plusieurs générations soient mortes
après que on est arrêté
les ou qu'on ait commencé à baisser les
émissions il ya une irréversibilité
fondamental dans cette histoire alors
pour vous qui est né à l'heure dé jeu
vidéo ou quand ça sent pas bon on appuie
sur le bouton reset et on est remis dans
la situation initiale
malheureusement là c'est une situation
dans laquelle n'y a pas de bouton reset
donc si à un moment quelconque on voit
que l'expérience nous déplaît la seule
garantie qu'on a à ce moment là c'est
que derrière c'est payant alors je sais
très bien que est du reste c'est le
propre de la jeunesse normalement à
votre agent dit on s'en fout même pas
peur puisque quand on est jeune on se
croit éternelle est invincible et
quelques vieux du reste encore aussi
mais il n'empêche qu'il faut quand même
bien y réfléchir parce que il n'y a
strictement aucune possibilité de retour
en arrière une fois que on constate que
le problème est hors de contrôle
gore
alors pour voir à peu près de quoi on
parle je vais vous montrer de cartes de
l'europe
vous avez ici une carte de l'europe qui
est la carte d'aujourd'hui à condition
qu'on n'est pas supprimé les écosystèmes
en place donc en fait ce que ça vous
montre ses les écosystèmes en place pour
y faire des chants des routes où le
bâtiment de télécom paris vous avez
essentiellement des forêts voilà à quoi
ressemble l'europe il ya vingt mille ans
dont je vous ai dit tout à l'heure il y
avait un bilan on est au coeur de la
dernière ère glaciaire et j'ai beaucoup
plus fort qu'aujourd'hui 1 et entre ya
entre entre à partir de ya vingt mille
ans a serré chauffer est ce que vous
voyez c'est que le paysage ne ressemble
pas du tout à celui que on constate
aujourd'hui
alors d'abord vous oubliez erasmus chez
nokia et ericsson en suède c'est juste
pas possible puisque les pays
scandinaves sont recouverts par une
calotte de trois kilomètres d'épaisseur
soit dit en passant les écossais ne
songe pas à faire sécession avec
l'angleterre suit aubrac site puisque
apa d'écossé et c'est pas une menace
pour le quinze de france puisqu'il ya
pas d co c'est la calotte qui s'est
constitué sur la scandinavie et une
autre encore plus grosses qui s'est
constitué sur le canada ont dû prendre
tellement d'eau là où il y en a c'est à
dire dans l'océan que l'océan qui est
une grande baignoire dont le fonds n'a
pas varié a baissé de 120 m donc pour
ceux d'entre vous qui vont participer à
la course de l'edhec pas de course de
l'edhec puisqu'il n'ya pas de manche
encore bosser au lieu de faire de la
voile
vous voyez également que les écosystèmes
installés en europe sont très différents
de ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
et en fait il ressemble peu ou prou à ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui au nord de la
sibérie
parce qu'il fait beaucoup plus froid et
beaucoup plus sec dans un climat très
froid il fait très ça qui peut
d'évaporation peu de précipitation et la
population mondiale
la population pardon française dans ce
genre de contexte à laisser les
effectifs des classes prépa en haut vous
avez cent mille personnes en bout de
chaîne alimentaire
occupé à ramasser des airelles et à
courir derrière les mammouths voilà ce
que vous avez dans la france de la
dernière ère glaciaire
vous voyez que ce monde très très
différente en sommes sortis entre
guillemets pour le meilleur puisqu'on a
rendu toutes les moyennes latitudes
cultivables grâce à la déglaciation et
bien cette déglaciation qui a fait
passer du paysage de gauche au paysage
de droite au niveau planétaire c'est
seulement un réchauffement de 5 degrés
donc vous voyez à quoi ça ressemble 5°
en cinq mille ans en cinq mille ans en
termes de conséquences
alors je vais un tout petit peu détaillé
maintenant les conséquences possibles du
changement climatique
mais retenez déjà cette conclusion très
simple c'est que quelques degrés de
variation en un siècle au surplus dans
un monde où l'énergie c'est à dire la
capacité à faire face va faire défaut
dans un nombre croissant de zone
c'est l'assurance d'avoir des conditions
stables qui fichent le camp à une telle
vitesse que ça va devenir conflictuelle
absolument partout d'accord donc le
réchauffement climatique
c'est certes des écosystèmes qui s'érode
une aide mais tout ça in fine et va
finir par les hommes qui vont se taper
dessus alors ils peuvent se taper dessus
de plein de manières ça peut être des
guerres ouvertes d'un pays à un autre à
peu des guerres civiles ça peut être de
l'oppression dictatorial et des camps
comme staline en plein de manières de
zigouiller ses semblables mais c'est
évident que ça va dynamiter les
démocratie prospère que nous avons
prospères et stables que nous avons
aujourd'hui
alors quelque conséquence un peu dans le
détail le cycle de l'eau va changer
globalement dans un monde plus chaud
vous avez plus d'évaporation dont plus
de précipitations mais ces
précipitations vont être répartis de
manière très inégale dans l'espace
c'est tout pour les hautes latitudes et
l'équateur est par contre les tropiques
vont souffrir et dans le temps c'est à
dire que ça va être concentrée sur plus
d'épisodes pluvieux intenses qui nous
intéresse absolument pas pour recharger
les sols en eau les épisodes pluvieux
intenses
l'eau ruisselle volcan et l epad utilise
pas d'une grande utilité pour la
végétation eu un exemple parmi d'autres
donc vous voyez que le pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen va devenir plus sec
est par ailleurs plus chauds comme
partout plus chaud et plus sec ça veut
dire que les forêts françaises vont
devenir plus inflammable
vous avez ici l'inflammabilité des
forêts françaises aujourd'hui et vous
l'avez dans vingt ans dans 20 ans vous
aurez même pas mon âge donc dans 20 ans
la forêt de fontainebleau pourra
commencer à cramer par exemple
ici vous avez les évolutions des
rendements agricoles en fonction enfin
deux enfants fonctionnent de la part de
la vie et de la nature ce que vous voyez
c'est que globalement ça passe partout
alors évidemment si on s'adapte ça
baisse un peu moins vite que si on
s'adapte pas mais c'est quand même on va
avoir des mauvaises surprises
et regardez même en france où elle est
capable de s'adapter puisqu'on a des
tracteurs des engrais machin etc 2018 on
a connu de mémoire -20% sur les céréales
-40% sur certaines cultures de pata tout
petits pois cette année les éleveurs
sont en train de souffrir le martyre
avec les fourrages qui sont en chute
libre
alors le blé va bien marcher et à
d'autres cultures qui vont qui vont
perdre et on est juste en 2019
on n'aura pas de fin en france par
contre clairement le prix de la
nourriture va un tout petit peu changé
les régimes alimentaires aussi et puis
dans des endroits où on mourra de faim
pour de vrai mais il ya des gens qui
vont se dire puisque on meurt pas de
faim en france on va traverser la
méditerranée
c'est absolument évident
voilà comment par ailleurs évolué la
surface cultivable par personne sur les
dernières décennies donc vous voyez
moins de surface par personne
des conditions qui vont devenir plus
adverse alors bon moment tout ça tient
grâce aux engrais aux phytosanitaires et
à la mécanisation
mais tout ça c'est de l'énergie donc
avec moins d'énergie petit sujet parlant
de l'ouragan d'orient ou plus exactement
de sa grande famille
ce que vous voyez ici c'est l'évolution
attendue en ce qui concerne les
phénomènes extrêmes alors un phénomène
extrême c'est quoi c'est ça démarre par
une convection puissante qui est mise en
oeuvre par un gradient de température
important dans l'atmosphère donc vous
allez à la surface de l'océan tropicale
là où c'est chaud la stratosphère et à
la même température partout - 50 et donc
plus c'est chaud en surface plus le
gradient verticale de température est
important et donc plus les mouvements
convectifs pas se développer de manière
forte et l'évaporation comme vous le
savez très bien pour l'avoir étudiée en
thermodynamique renforce ce phénomène de
convection avec la chaleur latente qui
est libéré et bien quand on augmente la
température de surface des océans on va
globalement augmenté la pompe à
fabriquer des mouvements convectifs
puissant et donc on va changer quelque
chose dans les phénomènes extrêmes
lorsque vous dit le dernier rapport du
giec c'est que vraisemblablement la
fréquence va pas changer
par contre l'intensité unitaire va
changer elle va augmenter et en fait on
a déjà en train de constater ce
phénomène
ça c'est un certain nombre de
conséquences du changement climatique
alors vous voyez qu évidemment les
conséquences augmente quand l'élévation
de température augmente et partout ça
commence à rentrer dans le rouge et le
violet c'est que vous avez des
conséquences étendues et irréversible et
par exemple à 2 degrés à peu près tous
les coraux de la planète sont morts
alors que c'est le seuil auquel on
essaye de se limiter et que pour le
moment on est loin d'être parti pour
atteindre car on est parti pour faire
beaucoup plus
un rapport qui vient de sortir sur le
changement climatique et les usages des
terres retenez les deux trucs de droite
là en gros il va y avoir des
instabilités d'approvisionnement
agricole qui vont se mettre à devenir
très importante à partir de 2 degrés
et quand les gens n'ont pas à manger
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont suivi un
cours d'histoire en 1788 ya eu une
grande famine c'est quand même par
hasard que la révolution soit arrivé en
1789 et c'est pas un cas isolé
le printemps arabe dont vous avez
peut-être entendu parler en 2011 c'est
aussi des émeutes de la faim
et ça ce document passait bien et c'est
aussi lié à des questions de climat et
d'énergie pas que mais aussi lié à des
questions climat et d'énergie
nous avons deux gros glaçons sur terre
qui sont le groenland et l'antarctique
là où c'est rouge c'est que l'altitude
diminue les deux ont commencé à être
atteint alors le groenland fond ça y est
c'est en route il va fondre en partie ou
en totalité alors est ce qui pourrait
lui éviter de fondre en totalité
c'est que le groenland est posée sur une
cuvette qui est partiellement sous
marine
et si on arrive à stabilité à stabiliser
un bout de glace au dessus du niveau de
la mer
parce que il est suffisamment l'hiver au
jeu pourquoi il ya on pourrait en garder
une partie mais ça il ya 3 à 6 mètres
d'eau dans l'océan mondial qui sont en
jeu à l'échelle de quelques siècles et
l'antarctique de l'ouest
c'est un ensemble de glaciers qui sont
en arcs boutants les uns contres les
autres sur un socle soir 1 mais qui lui
il est des versants d'un bout à l'autre
dans l'antarctique de l'ouest
d'accord il est il est incliné comme ça
donc vous n'avez pas du tout cet effet
de cuvette qui retient la glace et pour
ceux d'entre vous qui suivent
l'actualité
les émissaires l'aller les glaciers qui
sont en bout de chaîne qui sont ici sont
en train de filer vers la mer à un
rythme accéléré et derrière ça pourrait
déstabiliser l'ensemble des glaciers en
arcs boutants de l'antarctique de
l'ouest il ya au dernier rapport du giec
pardon dans cet article qui a été publié
l'auteur imagine que ça pourrait se
désagréger en quelques siècles
des recherches plus récentes montrent
que ça pourrait même arriver plus vite
que ça l'antarctique de l'ouest ces six
mètres dos en plus
oak la vous avez un point
d'interrogation sur 10 mètres dos en
plus pour l'océan mondial
en l'espace de n'importe quoi entre un
et cinq siècles
alors certes dans un siècle vous serez
mort vos enfants non et donc la question
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait sachant qu'il
dépend de nos actions la semaine
prochaine à cause du temps résidence du
co2 dans l'atmosphère
ça dépend de nos actions la semaine
prochaine j'insiste que quand je dis non
c'est pas des individus c'est la
collectivité aussi il ya des problèmes
politiques qu'on suit les choix qu'on
fait collectivement et c'est que
l'europe du nord ressemble ou pas à ça
dans quelques siècles le [ __ ] la balle
arrive dans quelques siècles le doigt
sur la détente c'est aujourd'hui et
comme je le redis il ya une
réversibilité fondamental dans cette
affaire de changement climatique car une
fois que le coup est parti
comme disait dubosc ça s'arrête plus il
ya d'autres conséquences qui sont
possibles dans cette affaire le
réchauffement va être plus rapide au
pôle cottereau pic ce qui veut dire que
la différence de température entre les
pôles et les tropiques va s'amenuiser et
ça va engendrer deux types de
conséquences
ainsi que la circulation océanique à
large échelle va se modifier et de une
deuxième conséquence qu'on est déjà en
train de constater c'est que la limite
séparative entre le climat polaire et le
climat des moyennes latitudes va
s'affaiblir avec des incursions d'air
chaud beaucoup plus fréquents entre des
pôles et des incursions d'air froid
beaucoup plus fréquentes aux moyennes
latitudes et ça vous l'avait déjà
constaté dans ce qui s'est passé les
deux dernières années avec des extraits
de froid ce suivi de record de chaud
juste à moi derrière des climats qui
prennent ou des amplitudes de 15 20
degrés en l'espace de quelques jours
et bien ça c'est typiquement liés à cet
affaiblissement de la limite séparative
dont je viens de vous parler entre le
climat polaire et le climat qui reste
quand même plus froid que le nôtre et le
climat des moyennes latitudes
quand on chauffe le bouillon de culture
les petites bêtes apprécie donc la
biodiversité des agents pathogènes va se
modifier
et enfin vous avez des stocks de carbone
qui était fixé pour depuis des milliers
millions d'années qui vont être remis en
circulation
parce que le compartiment dans lequel
ils sont se déstabilise et c'est
notamment vrai pour le permafrost
c'est à dire du sol gelé en permanence
qui est des gelées depuis des millions
d'années et qui va libérer du carbone
qui est contenu alors retenez dans cette
affaire la phrase du bas vous avez tous
fait des expériences sur paillasse tous
d'accord il vous et à tous arrivés que
de temps en temps le résultat de
l'expérience n'était pas celui attendu
et pourtant c'est une expérience où les
conditions enfin j'veux dire normalement
on sait à peu près ce qui doit se passer
on connaît le processus expliqué en ce
qui concerne le changement climatique
on est dans une expérience qui est une
première du genre sur un système qui est
monstrueusement complexe puisque c'est
la totalité de l'humanité la totalité du
vivant la tête et herat dont un talent
dont on n'a pas cerner encore tous les
mécanismes de fonctionnement
donc la seule chose absolument certaine
je dis bien la seule chose absolument
certaine dans cette affaire c'est que
plus le changement climatique s'amplifie
plus on aura des surprises
c'est à dire des trucs qu'on n'aura pas
vu venir à l'avance on est déjà un peu
dans ce genre malheureusement de
processus aujourd'hui quand on regarde
la science c'est à dire qu'il ya des
trucs qu'on voit venir
on était en personne de s'en doutait il
ya quelques années et c'est évident que
ça va s'amplifier alors une société qui
doit répondre à des trucs qu'elle n'est
pas capable de comprendre enfin de voir
venir à l'avance c'est toujours beaucoup
plus compliqué que si on les voit venir
à l'avance c'est absolument évident
alors si on dit très bien on veut pas de
cette expérience désagréable
on a bien compris donc on oublie on
oublie la croissance du pib et on
s'intéresse à la décroissance du co2
voilà une autre droite absolument
cardinal dans ce que je vous montre
aujourd'hui et qui relie de façon très
simple alors si un ensemble de
simulation mais ça décrit une droite la
quantité totale de gaz carbonique que
nous mettrons dans l'atmosphère entre
l'ère préindustrielle et 2100 et la
hausse de température planétaire entre
l'ère préindustrielle et 2100 oui c'est
très simple sud droite à leurs
applications numériques afin 2018
on a mis un peu plus de 2200 milliards
de tonnes de co2 dans l'atmosphère
depuis l'ère préindustrielle et donc
nous avons déjà signé pour un degré et
demi donc en fait les 1 degré et demi
dans l'accord de paris ont dit on va
faire nos meilleurs efforts pour limiter
en fait ils sont déjà embarqué avec ce
qu'on a déjà évident les scénarios qui
sont contenues dans le rapport spécial
du giec sur les 1,5 degré suppose tout
ce que les émissions on continue à faire
d'ici à 2050 pas beaucoup soit dit en
passant sont compensés par de la
séquestration net qu'on se met à faire à
partir de 2050 c'est à dire que à partir
de 2050 l'humanité non seulement deux
mais plus une tonnes additionnelles dans
l'atmosphère mais retire des tonnes de
l'atmosphère avec tout un tas de
procéder alors la croissance des arbres
capture du co2 pourquoi retire de
l'atmosphère
si on pense qu'on sera pas capable de
retirer du co2 qu'on a déjà mis de
l'atmosphère qu'on a déjà mis dans
l'atmosphère à ce moment les émissions
doivent s'arrêter demain matin pour
qu'on tienne les 1,5 degré si on veut
les deux degrés là on a encore le droit
d'émettre un peu on a le droit d'émettre
1 ce qui permet d'aller jusqu'à 3000
milliards de tonnes aux incertitudes de
modélisation près parce que les
incertitudes de modélisation que vous
avez ici
en fait elles vous disent que les deux
degrés eh bien peut-être que dans la
version la plus optimiste on pourrait
aller jusqu'à 5000 milliards de tonnes
et ne pas les dépasser mais dans la
version la plus pessimiste à 2500 les a
déjà dépassé et vous savez comme moi
qu'une grande incertitude est un grand
facteur de risque il faut pas croire que
l'incertitude c'est une police
d'assurance
si je vous dis je vais vous bandé les
yeux et vous faire traverser bourg et
les champs elysées à 4h30 du matin
c'est pas sûr que vous mourriez pour
passer alors il ya une grande
incertitude
je suis pas sûr que vous allez faire
l'essai non plus si je vous dis il ya
une grande incertitude pour que la
prochaine fois que vous montrez dans un
avion ce qui est très mal vous avez
compris à partir de maintenant il ya une
grande incertitude sur le fait que vous
allez arriver vivant vous n'allez pas
prendre ça comme une police d'assurance
donc en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique c'est pareil faut surtout pas
prendre la grande incertitude comme le
fait que l'on risque rien une grande
incertitude
c'est aussi une grande incapacité à
mettre une bourde supérieurs aux risques
concours pour aussi de voir comme ça
donc d'un degré c'est 3000
ça veut dire que il nous reste huit
cents 750 pour être précis milliards de
tonnes à émettre alors qu'on en a déjà
émis 2250 dont je vais vous le dire
autrement ça veut dire que la génération
que vous représentez vous avez le droit
à votre vie durant
au tiers des émissions qu'on hugo grands
parents leur vie durant pour l'ensemble
des hommes alors que vous êtes trois
fois plus nombreux c'est à dire que par
individu vous avez un crédit émission
sur l'ensemble de votre vie qui est le
neuvième de celui qu'on vous rend pas
rentrer
c'est ça les deux degrés c'est évident
la rente est des questions sur le sujet
qu' aujourd'hui la classe politique est
totalement à l'ouest quand elle explique
qu'on va régler le problème les doigts
dans le nez tout en assurant la
croissance économique et je sais pas
quoi ils sont juste totalement à l'ouest
accord soit ils n'ont pas fait de
physique soit ils en ont fait et ils se
dépêchent de l'oublier pour les
provinces électorale mais c'est évident
que c'est juste inenvisageable marchera
pas pour les deux degrés ce qu'il
faudrait faire c'est diviser les
émissions planétaires par trois d'ici à
ce que vous ayez mon âge c'est ça qu'il
faudrait faire alors on va voir dans à
peu près d'où elles sortent et puis
après je ferai une petite incursion sur
le digital et puis après je m'arrête
voilà un camembert qui vous représente
la totalité des émissions planétaires
alors 20% dans le camembert que je vous
présente la sont le fait des seules
centrales à charbon
quand on va pour cent des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre tougas confondues
c'est les centrales à charbon donc une
des conséquences évidentes
si on est sérieux sur les 2 degrés c'est
qu'à partir de maintenant on en
construit plus une seule est qu on a 30
ans pour dézinguer toutes celles qu'on a
[Musique]
7% des émissions planétaires c'est les
centrales à gaz et à fuel 6%
c'est les cimenteries alors les
cimenteries sont particulières dans
l'industrie parce qu'il vous faut de la
chaleur donc vous allez brûler des
combustibles pour chauffer les fours un
four c'est juste un endroit dans lequel
vous portez à très haute température du
carbonate de calcium donc caco3 que vous
allez casser en deux en gardant ses
assauts d'un côté c'est à dire de la
chaux vive qui mélangeait avec quelques
poudre de perlimpinpin vous fera le
ciment et de l'autre côté vous avez du
co2 qui fout le camp dans l'atmosphère
donc un four de cimenterie c'est un
grand tube en métal un peu un peu gros
dans lequel vous rentrez votre carbonate
de requêtes sur votre carbonate de
calcium
c'est à dire du calcaire venant d'une
carrière avec quelques additifs vous
faites tourner le four ou chauffer très
fort et ça vous sort du plain caire qui
ensuite deviendra du ciment c'est pour
ça que le ciment est très agressif pour
ceux d'entre vous qui ont déjà banni
pelé à mains nues vous avez vu que ça
vous bouffer la peau parce que ça
contient deux en fait c'est un composé
de chaux vive
cette réaction et met donc du co2 et
donc les cimenteries dans le monde ces
six pour cent des émissions planétaires
la totalité des cimenteries dans le
monde pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur comparatif les françaises ca et
demi pour cent des émissions donc le
cimenterie c'est pas rien
le reste de l'industrie en émissions
directes c'est 12% drakkar lequel les
aciéries à elle toute seule fois aux 6
4% donc faire du béton et d'acier
c'est 10 % des émissions planétaires
dont construire des logements partout où
des villes et des ponts ça y est les
chaudières de bâtiments c'est 6% en
direct vous allez dire c'est pas
beaucoup parce qu'en france c'est
beaucoup plus que ça oui la france est
un pays des moyennes latitudes on
chauffe
tous les pays ne se chauffera la france
n'a pas de centrale à charbon donc les
20% disparaissent et c'est donc cette
part de camembert peuvent être
différentes dans différents pays
les transports ces 14 dans lesquelles
les voitures c6 les camions c4 et la
marine et l'aviation
ces deux chacun ce que vous voyez là
c'est que par exemple les cimenteries
dans le monde sa et mais autant que les
voitures particulières autant ce que
vous voyez c'est que les centrales à
charbon émettent à elle seule plus que
la totalité des moyens de transport ans
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut [ __ ] le
peuple foutent la paix aux
automobilistes c'est parce que je suis
en train de vous dire je suis juste en
train de vous dire que il ne faut pas
croire que dans cette affaire-là il
suffit de se concentrer sur un secteur
en disant là j'ai un usage dont je vais
m'occuper et ça règle le problème
malheureusement l'énergie a tout fait
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure elle est partout superman s'est
invité partout nos esclaves mécaniques
sont partout donc il va falloir
s'occuper de tout 20%
c'est l'alimentation alors enfin c'est
l'agriculture pourrait plus précis et
donc là c'est essentiellement des
émissions de méthane la fermentation
entérique des rivières et c'est aussi
des émissions alors là j'avais pas
d'image sympathique pour vous montrer ce
que c'est c'est les émissions qui
résultent de l'épandage des engrais par
terre quand vous épandez des engrais
azotés
vous avez une réaction qui de réduction
qui se produit avec une partie des
nitrates ce que vous mettez par terre
qui vous donne un gaz qui est le n2o qui
soit dit en passant est aussi le gaz
hilarant donc si vous quand vous étiez
petit vous êtes allez vous faire
arracher une dent enfin en parachute
dans recoudre une joue pas ce que vous
avez fait le zazou eh bien on vous a
fait respirer du protoxyde d'azoté pour
vous anesthésiée
dix pour cent des émissions c'est la
déforestation qui est un processus à
bons de l'agriculture puisque la
déforestation vise essentiellement à
couper des surfaces en forêt pour en
faire des champions fallait couper les
brûler et c'est donc si vous aimez pas
la déforestation il ya deux sujets qui
doit vous préoccupez 1 c'est le planning
familial parce que plus on est nombreux
plus on a besoin surfaces cultivables et
deux si la quantité de viande qu'on
mange par personne parce que plus on
mange d'animaux et puis on a besoin de
surfaces cultivées pour nourrir les
animaux et enfin les quelques pourcents
qui reste c'est des poudres de
perlimpinpin d'hiver le traitement des
déchets les chaînes de les fuites de
chaîne du froid etc
voilà je choisis ton camp camarade on
prend ça est faux le divisé par trois en
trente ans ou est-ce que je tape alors
là dedans j'en arrive à la
digitalisation est-ce que la
digitalisation va nous aider à résoudre
le problème alors dans un premier temps
elles augmentent elles augmentent parce
que la digitalisation c'est pas
dématérialisée à ce que ce serait ce que
je sache ça c'est parfaitement matériel
mon smartphone qui est en l'occurrence
un dogme phone est parfaitement matériel
et les éléments de réseau que vos
prédécesseurs ont installé partout chez
orange et chez leurs petits copains sont
parfaitement matériel et les data
centers sont parfaitement matériel et
les centrales électriques qui permet de
faire fonctionner tout ça sont
parfaitement matériel donc c'est pas du
tout dématérialisé c'est une escroquerie
de dire que c'est dématérialisé c'est un
autre substrat que le papier les
imprimés alors pour faire ce substrat
qu'est ce qu'il faut eh bien vous avez
20 à 40 métaux par engin que vous allez
trouver dans le monde du digital dans un
ordinateur là vous êtes plutôt plus
proche de 40
un smartphone donc ces métaux faut aller
les chercher donc faut des mines il faut
de la chimie du verre de l'acier et
c'est alors qu'il faut fabriquer des
matériaux de base
il faut des produits dérivés du pétrole
donc il faut de l'exploitation
pétrolière
ça c'est les vitres il faut de l'eau
purifiée dans certains endroits c'est
une machine à purifier de l'eau il faut
des chaînes d'assemblage
il faut construire les boîtes dans
lesquelles on fait tout ça il faut
transporter les trucs intermédiaire il
faut lancer des fusées ariane
il faut il faut il faut donc en fait il
faut plein de trucs extrêmement matériel
pour que le système fonctionne le
résultat des courses c'est que quand
vous fabriquer un ordinateur aujourd'hui
vous émettez une demi tonne de co2 dans
l'atmosphère plus la diagonale d'écran
est importante plus les émissions par
fabrication par ordinateurs fabriqués
sont importants c'est exactement pareil
pour les écrans connectés plus la
diagonale d'écran est importante plus
les émissions de fabrication sont
importantes et quand vous regardez d'où
viennent les et vous avez également des
métaux comme vous pouvez le voir quand
vous regardez d'où viennent les
émissions du système
en fait elles viennent pour moitié au
plan mondial de la fabrication des
composants les téléphones les
ordinateurs les écrans connectés et pour
moitié du fonctionnement de cet ensemble
alors en france la proportion n'est pas
du tout la même parce que en moyenne
mondiale voulait dit tout à l'heure 65 %
d'électricité fossiles c'est pas vrai en
france
en france ces quelques pourcents
d'électricité qui sont fausses il donc
le fonctionnement est essentiellement
décarbonés la fabrication non pour un en
france pour un engin comme ça
le ratio entre fabrication et
fonctionnement ses cent à 1 donc en
france si on veut être sobre sur le plan
numérique
la solution est extrêmement simple on
achète le moins souvent possible
ordinateurs smartphones et écran est le
plus petit possible simplicité biblique
c'est pas vraiment ça qu'on va vous
encourager à faire pendant vos études
mais c'est très exactement ça qu'il faut
pas faire
et vous voyez que la vertu n'est pas en
vue puisque les émissions de fabrication
là on prend l'exemple d'un constructeur
bien connus ont tendance à augmenter par
terminal avec le temps le numérique est
une des rares industries dans le monde
dans lequel le contenu carbone d'un
dollars de ventes augmentent avec le
temps diby dupas ya zéro efficacité avec
le temps ils augmentent
et si jacques grège toutes les émissions
de fabrication et de fonctionnement du
numérique
voilà à quoi ça ressemble donc là dedans
je met encore une fois à la fabrication
des réseaux télécoms leur maintenance le
fonctionnement des réseaux télécoms je
mets la fabrication des terminaux donc
encore une fois smartphone ordinateur
écran la fabrication des serveurs de
l'autre côté et le fonctionnement des
serveurs tout ça et bien il ya quelques
années c'était équivalent aux émissions
du transport aérien
aujourd'hui c'est équivalent aux
émissions de la flotte mondiale de
camions 4 % des émissions mondiales et
au train où ça va d'ici quelques années
seulement
ça sera équivalent aux émissions de la
flotte mondiale de voitures si vous
appelez ça du développement durable moi
je veux bien moi non pas du tout c'est
pas du tout durable pas du tout du tout
du tout du tout du tout il n'y a rien de
moins durables que ça donc la
digitalisation aujourd'hui c'est un
inducteur de flux par ailleurs il ya une
deuxième raison pour laquelle c'est un
adducteur de flux vous allez comprendre
très simplement
si demain matin je supprime d'un coup de
baguette magique tous les ordinateurs
dans le monde
alors vous allez vous emmerdez parce que
vous pourrez plus regarder vos
smartphones en conférence mais à part ça
et bien est-ce que vous pensez que le
trafic aérien reste au niveau auquel il
est aujourd'hui est ce qu'on sait gérer
le trafic aérien mondial aujourd'hui
sans ordinateur évidemment que non
est ce que je sais gérer aujourd'hui la
totalité des usines mondiales avec leurs
flux juste à temps sans ordinateur
évidemment que non
est ce que je sais gérer tous les robots
de production de toutes les usines sans
ordinateur évidemment que non
ce tout petit raisonnement très simple
vous permet de comprendre que
l'informatique le digital dans le monde
globalement est un facilitateur de
l'augmentation des flux et pas du tout
un économiseur de flux
et pas de tout quelque chose qui sert à
être globalement sobre c'est quelque
chose qui sert à augmenter la quantité
de flux congères donc aujourd'hui le
digital non je suis désolé de vous dire
ça au début de vos études maintenant
vous pouvez plus changé d'avis tant pis
pour vous aviez qu'à faire 5 2 me mais
le digital aujourd'hui n'est pas du tout
insiste là-dessus
quelque chose qui permet de rendre le
système productif mondiale plus sobre
c'est quelque chose qui le rend plus
comment parce que plus beau temps plus
capable de gérer des grands flux par
ailleurs je voulais dit tout à l'heure
vous avez une quarantaine de métaux
différents dans un ordinateur ou un
smartphone
et ces métaux sont présents à des
concentrations telle une fois qu'ils
sont dans l'appareil que leur recyclage
est un tout petit sujet théoriquement on
peut recycler n'importe quoi tant qu'on
n'a pas de problème d'accès à l'énergie
puisque c'est quoi le recyclage c'est
l'énergie c'est utiliser de l'énergie
pour séparer physiquement ou
chimiquement l'élément qui vous
intéressent de tout le reste
donc si vous n'avez pas de problème
d'accès à l'énergie
vous pouvez tous recyclés indéfiniment
c'est juste pas un sujet vous séparez
d'accord au besoin vous passez tout dans
un spectromètre de masse et vous
récupérez les atomes à part un juste pas
de problème bah oui si vous avez une
énergie infinie et vous avez une
affinité spectromètre de masse
donc il ya pas de problème vous séparer
tout mais comme on n'a pas une énergie
infinie
en fait on ne recycle le rap à la
totalité de ce qu'on met aujourd'hui
dans les appareils électroniques et vous
avez ici hein
vous avez une personne qui travaille là
dessus pas très loin d'ici à jussieu là
josé aloi et au lied et là vous avez ici
un rapport qui est sorti il ya pas très
longtemps qui vous donne le taux de
recyclage pour un certain nombre de
matériaux dans le monde et vous voyez
qu'une partie des matériaux qu'on
utilise dans les smartphones sont dans
les cases rouges
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le taux de
recyclage il est quasi nulle
et enfin dans les autres trucs qui sont
pas vraiment durable c'est que
l'espérance de vie d'un smartphone ces
18 mois
donc en gros 18 mois séparent le moment
où alors un peu plus parce qu'il faut
entre le moment où vous êtes là elle
moment où vous êtes là donc c'est pareil
il ya rien de moins durable et puis
aujourd'hui les fabricants mettent
beaucoup d'ingéniosité à faire en sorte
que les trucs tombe en panne le plus
vite possible donc enfin pas durable du
tout voilà j'ai quasiment terminés cet
exposé je vais quand même finir avec une
petite touche d'espoir
admettons que les européens se disent
bon très bien on est profondément dans
le caca sauf que nous les européens on a
un avantage dans ce cas c'est que la
contrainte physique on connaît ça depuis
plus longtemps que les autres
l'europe a connu la famine la maladie et
enfin bon bref tout a pas de limites
physiques qui nous sont familières
on a un grand concurrent dans le monde
s'appelle les états unis qui est le pays
de l'absence de limites
alors no limit est du reste tout le pays
a été construit pour que chacun puisse
compter sur ses propres forces
puisque comme vous êtes dans un pays
sans limite de toute façon tout le monde
a accès à autant de ressources qui veut
donc vous aller quelque part vous
installez vous tuer et tuer les indiens
prod et la terre creusée dans la mine
vous prend dès lors voilà
et on efface finalement monstrueux
problèmes d'optimisation sous contrainte
on restaure que l'optimisation sous
contrainte c'est une des forces notre
pays dire qu'on sait pas tout faire bien
mais il ya un truc qu'on fait pas mal
c'est ça et à ce moment on se dit bon
très bien on oublie les problèmes de
croissance infinie là de toute façon on
leur a pas ça va poser quelques tout
petits sujets par exemple les dettes
sont pas remboursés enfin seront pas
remboursés au nominal ceci étant ces
hausses et déjà ce qu'on voit apparaître
la contraction énergétique européenne
engendre déjà des taux négatifs comme au
japon comme dans une partie des pays du
monde où aujourd'hui l'économie ne croît
plus ou en tout cas plus la bonne
vitesse donc de toutes façons les
rentiers c'est à dire vos parents contre
l'assurance vie seront tendus mais
autant qu'il le soit pour des raisons
utile donc on dit très bien on oublie
c'est pas ça le sujet à ce moment
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on fait o'shea
project on a travaillé sur un programme
en neuf axes et soit dit en passant il
ya le président d'un grand syndicat
professionnel en france qui est l'union
des industries métallurgiques et
minières qui a dit à peu près la même
chose que nous dans une tribune dans les
échos il ya quelques jours je suis resté
assis sur ma chaise
il a dit on a besoin de remettre en
place une commission planification pour
qu'on roule plan que qu'on a été très
bon qui donne des perspectives de long
terme filière par filière pour que les
gens sachent quoi faire sous-entendu
même s'il ya une contrainte au moins que
on comprenne pourquoi celle là et qu'on
la met dans la durée alors si on se
place au niveau européen parce que
c'était ça nous notre cahier des charges
voilà ce qu'il faut faire 1 on ferme
toutes les centrales à charbon fermer
toutes les centrales à charbon le mode
le plus économique pour les remplacer
j'ai pas tant rentrer dans les détails
aujourd'hui il ya des questions j'ai
repassé devant remplacer à part du
nucléaire
c'est beaucoup plus économique que de
remplacer sa part des modes qui sont non
pilotable parce que le vote non
pilotable comme les gens ont la mauvaise
idée de consommer d'électricité même la
nuit et même quand il ya des
anticyclones il vous dit pas toute
l'histoire est celle intermittence
induites dans le système qui devient à
des merdes abl
la deuxième chose c'est que il faut
contracter la quantité de transport
individuel que nous utilisons c'est à
dire moins de voitures les faire
beaucoup plus petit et beaucoup plus
légère donc en gros il faut faire des
voitures de 500 kg qui consomme 2 litres
au cent et derrière on les passera à
l'électrique ce sera très facile si on
commence par faire des chars d'automne à
l'électricité on va perdre la partie
il faut également augmenter la quantité
de services mutualisés alors ça peut
être du covoiturage des transports en
commun du train etc
enfin tout ce qui permet d'être
plusieurs dans un véhicule il ya un
petit truc qui est essentiel pour la
paix en europe selon nous c'est que avec
de moins en moins de pétrole vous aurez
de moins en moins d'avions ça va bien
finir par arriver un jour et à ce moment
pour conserver des échanges entre pays
parce que c'est effectivement les
échanges entre pays ils permettent de
stabiliser la paix il faut avoir des
trains on avait des trains très
performant à un moment donc il faudra
développer les trains ensuite on a tous
petits sujets dans l'industrie faire
trois fois moins d'émissions de co2 dans
le ciment à part fabriqué trois fois
moins de ciment moi j'en fais aussi on
peut en fabriquer que deux fois moins
mais je veux dire à un moment on tombe
sur des asymptote en ce qui concerne ce
qu'on est capable de gagner en rendement
physique
donc on va avoir besoin de faire mieux
avec moins
ce qui veut dire que l'on fabriquera
moins d'objets ils seront plus réparable
du coup les parcs se renouvelleront
moins vite donc le progrès technique
diffusant à moins vite c'est un truc il
faut bien garder en tête et la structure
des métiers changera exactement comme
quand j'étais jeune y avait des tas de
gens qui savent et réparait des tas
d'objets qui aujourd'hui ont disparu
parce que en fabriquons jette parce que
l'énergie abondante fait que c'est pas
intéressant de réparer des machins c'est
plus intéressant de fabrique est jetée
puis en plus comme ça la nouveauté la
plus vite s'il a une espérance de vie de
votre smartphone était de 20 ans et pas
de 18 mois vous auriez l'air du nord
d'où il parce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui l'a
acheté un an après vous qui pendant 19
ans un truc est mieux que le vôtre
dans le bâtiment il faut s'occuper de
rendre les bâtiments compatible avec la
quantité d'énergie dont on va disposer
c'est à dire pas beaucoup donc il faut
les protéger du froid et de plus en plus
du show est de plus en plus du show pour
ceux d'entre vous qui ont passé le mois
de juillet à paris il y en a peut-être
un certain nombre d'entre vous qui
aurait préféré habiter ailleurs
en tout cas je peux vous dire que dans
les gens qui travaillent chez moi il y
en a qui sont dans ce cas là ils ont
même carrément pas pu rester chez eux il
habitait au dernier étage où je sais pas
quoi donc on va avoir un sujet sur le
froid certes mais on voit de plus en
plus avoir un sujet sur le show parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre qu'avec
l'inertie du système la canicule de
juillet dernier
nous n'avons encore rien vu par rapport
à ce qui sera la normale dans 50 ans
pareil en ce qui concerne les bâtiments
d'activités donc il faut s'occuper des
bâtiments un tertiaire et d'activités il
faut redévelopper la forêt et d'une
manière générale il faut s'occuper des
ressources biologiques de façon beaucoup
plus sérieuse qu'on le fait aujourd'hui
ça veut dire remettre du monde dans
l'agriculture le prix de la bouffe
augmentera ainsi soit il il faut donc
beaucoup mieux capter ce potentiel
photosynthétiques que nous avons
aujourd'hui
et enfin comme le cheptel bovin est à la
fois une source de pression agricole et
une source d'émissions directes
il faut beaucoup moins de vaches donc en
gros il faut diviser le cheptel bovin
par deux à trois mais comme les éleveurs
font un métier beaucoup plus difficile
que vous que je veux pas leur mort ça
veut dire aussi que il faut revenir à
des systèmes de prix encadrés et donc je
vais finir sur quelques mesures
transverse le tout marché partout ça
marche pas penser qu'on va investir sur
50 ans sur la base des prix de la
semaine dernière c'est à l'heure c'est
une illusion
je pense qu'il faut supprimer la
cotation en continu des entreprises donc
tous ceux d'entre vous qui rêverait
d'aller dans le système informatique
d'une banque
ils ont beaucoup moins de job je pense
que c'est indispensable de faire ça il
faut supprimer les comptes trimestriels
aussi typiquement des trucs qui servent
qu'à mettre de la volatilité partout
voilà donc ya pas que des mesures
techniques qu'il faut faire il ya aussi
un certain nombre de ventes fin c'est
toujours des mesures techniques mais
c'est des mesures organisationnelles
donc ce que je suis en train de vous
dire vous comprenez que ça s'appelle un
programme politique donc j'ai aucune
intention de me présenter aux élections
mais vous comprenez que ça s'appelle un
programme politique puisque c'est
holistique l'énergie ayant pouvait
s'occuper sérieusement de transition
c'est s'occuper de tout temps qu'on
pensera qu'il suffit de nommer un
ministre un peu sympathique et le foot
dans un coin en lui disant fais moi
trois trucs et deux éoliennes pour que
j'ai je sois populaire dans les colonnes
de journaux
on passera à côté de l'essentiel du
problème en fait on passera à côté de la
totalité du problème donc ce n'est pas
un prêtre 2010 cette affaire sert pas de
président voilà je terminais cette
conférence c'était super sinon plus que
ce que je voulais savoir c'est pour
s'informer en fait justement sur ces
questions là où est ce qu'on peut avoir
accès en fait à des sources fiables des
résultats enfin vérifier
scientifiquement et pour avoir comme
vous ne les montre et finalement une
réelle perspective sur ce qui est en
train de se passer en ce qui concerne
toute la partie climat l'information
primaire se trouve dans les documents
qui sont édités par le giec
c'est à dire le groupe
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat qui dispose d'un site qui en
anglais s'appelle ipcc internacional
panel on climate change point ch parce
qu'il est hébergé en suisse vous avez
alors d'une manière générale la question
qui est posée est une question
essentielle est ce que vous savez dans
cet amphi définir la légitimité
scientifique de quelqu'un il n'y a même
pas une main qui se lève
si oui alors ça tient effectivement la
publication en fait la légitimité
scientifique
alors je parle des sciences dures sur
l'essentiel de mon propos la légitimité
scientifique où la légitimité de l'
expertise de quelqu'un elle ne
s'acquiert que d'une seule manière c'est
par la publication dans des revues
scientifiques et techniques à comité de
lecture des propos qui sont ensuite
avancé dans une autre enceinte d'accord
donc vous avez une règle de processus
absolument essentiel qu'il faut que la
personne ait suivi toute personne qui
vulgarise ne peut s'appuyer que sur ça
donc une personne qui vulgarise ne peut
s'appuyer sur la science 1 ne peut
s'appuyer que ce qui a été fournie dans
les revues scientifiques à comité de
lecture alors il faut que le giec fait
la synthèse de ces publications
donc c'est là que vous avez
l'information primaires tout ce qui est
dans le journal c'est de l'information
en bout de chaîne
mais vous savez pas si le journaliste a
bien ou mal travailler s'il s'est
approvisionné auprès des bons relais et
c'est de savoir ce qui concerne
l'énergie c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
parce que vous avez alors vous avez une
source statistique qui est assez fiable
qui est édité par bp un truc qui
s'appelle bp statistical review
vous avez un énorme tableur avec toutes
toutes les séries de toutes les
consommations production dans tous les
pays du monde c'est un super bien fait
vous avez les statistiques de la banque
mondiale qui fonctionne après pour avoir
des analyses sur tout ça c'est là que ça
commence à devenir plus difficile parce
que la littérature sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique dans le
monde est essentiellement une
littérature jeu par contre j'aurais
appelé grises c'est-à-dire que les
informations sur lesquelles vous pouvez
vous basez pour faire des analyses sont
pour partie des informations détenues
par des opérateurs commerciaux qui les
rendent pas public et donc là c'est très
compliqué d'avoir un panorama un peu
large
sans aller à la pêche à droite et à
gauche mais vous avez quand même
quelques sites dont la banque mondiale
l'énergie information agency aux états
unis est également une bonne source de
statistiques et après vous avez quelques
blogs spécialisés de gens qui vous
décortique ces trucs là toujours une
information dont vous avez du mal au
moment où vous la lisez à savoir ce
qu'elle vaut exactement donc vous savez
que la personne qui parle connaît à peu
près son sujet est ce qu'à un moment il
a volontairement omis un truc pas simple
en ce qui concerne le nucléaire vous
avez un site sur la partie dangerosité
du nucléaire qui est un truc dans la
presse française ne parle absolument
jamais qui est aussi un site des nations
unies qui est s'appelle une star
u n sceam point org une star ça veut
dire united nations scientific committee
andy effects of atomic radiations c'est
la source de littérature scientifique
compilé notamment sur tchernobyl
fukushima etc et c'est le truc que la
presse française ne cite jamais parce
qu'il préfère reprendre des propos sorti
d'un chapeau qui circulent ailleurs en
ce qui concerne le voilà alors il faut
que vous aurez commencer à graviter un
peu là dedans et alors le dernier truc
il faut savoir que je prenne le temps de
vous lister toutes les sources c'est que
quand vous allez à la pêche aux infos ça
c'est aussi un truc que je vous invite
vraiment à garder dans votre cervelle il
ya deux trucs qui sont absolument en
capitaux le premier c'est que tant que
vous n'avez pas une vue cohérente du
problème en fin de sujet que vous avez
en face de vous c'est qu'il vous manque
une pièce donc temps que vous êtes à
temps vous avez des contradictions entre
les sources que vous n'arrivez pas à
résoudre c'est que vous n'êtes pas allé
jusqu'au bout de votre démarche parce
que nécessairement l'un des deux a
raison le croit tort donc donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut vous continuiez à
investiguer et l'avait l'information
primaire je le redis elle est auprès des
gens qui sont dans le secteur
c'est vrai pour la physique des
particules c'est vrai pour l'analyse
isotopique des glaçons c'est vrai aussi
pour les gens qui savent comment
fonctionne un puits de pétrole et de
centrales nucléaires ou une éolienne
c'est les gens du secteur qu'on la
meilleure info
le la deuxième chose c'est que à partir
du moment où vous commencez à avoir une
vue que vous considérez comme étant
correctement documenté sur la question
tous modèles sophistiqués qui ne colle
pas avec ce que vous dit une règle de
trois ou un calcul d'ordre de grandeur
bien posé signifie que le modèle à tort
et la seule question est de savoir où
[Musique]
d'accord et des gens qui vous utilisent
des modèles sophistiqués pour dire des
conneries dans le domaine économique en
particulier et en a pléthore alors
pléthore et alors ça c'est beaucoup plus
long à débusquer
je vais vous donner un dernier un
exemple dans ce domaine là vous savez
peut-être pour certains d'entre vous
qu'il ya dans ce pays une agence qui
s'occupe des économies d'énergie qui
s'appelle l'ademe
bon elle est également en charge des
énergies renouvelables ce qui fait
qu'elle a envie de dire du mal de tout
ce qui n'est pas renouvelable et en
particulier du nucléaire puisque en
france c'est sûr tout ça quand on
s'occupe donc ils disent pas beaucoup de
mal du pétrole mais ils disent du mal du
nucléaire ils ont sorti il ya quelques
temps un rapport qui a fait un peu de
bruit dans la presse qui s'appelait 100%
renouvelable et alors ils ont laissé la
presse dire que on voyait qu'il est
possible et que ça coûte pas plus cher
laurent fait le rapport a été fait avec
un modèle qui est tautologique sais ce
que c'est qu'un modèle tautologique
c'est un modèle dans lequel vous
retrouver en sortie l'hypothèse que vous
avez fait en entrée et la façon dont
fonctionne ce truc là c'est je suppose
que les énergies renouvelables coûte pas
cher que j'ai pas besoin de stocker que
le consommateur va s'adapter sans qu'ils
aient besoin d'investir et que j'ai pas
besoin d'adapter les réseaux et en
sortie je vous dis le système coûte pas
cher ok sauf que la vraie question à
l'ehpad en est ce que le modèle est
valable puisque effectivement avec les
hypothèses posées la sortie est valable
la vraie question c'est est-ce que les
hypothèses sont pertinentes
bon donc la voyez débusquer ce genre de
truc c'est beaucoup plus long donc ça ça
va vous demander beaucoup plus de temps
bonjour merci pour votre travail très
intéressant
moi j'aimerais savoir ce que vous pensez
de la smart city puisque je crois savoir
que cédric villani qui se présente plus
ou moins pour la mairie de paris est
assez emballé par l'idée
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je pense à peu près savoir votre réponse
à donner envie de file bihouix mais je
n'en pense rien parce que tant vous
n'avez pas défini ce que cette étude
smartcity je n'en pense rien est-ce que
tu partes city c'est une city ou votre
canapé vous papouilles les épaules quand
vous avez des crampes
est ce que c'est une city dans laquelle
les oeufs se cuisent tout seul au
supermarché parce que vous avez pensé à
des os dur est ce qu'en fait c'est quoi
une smart city pour voilà donc tant
qu'on n'a pas défini de ce parti
ça les smart c'est comme verts c'est un
truc qui est baguette magique donc temps
vous n'avez pas défini ce que c'était
qu'une smart city ben je n'en pense rien
alors est ce qu'il serait possible du
coup d'utiliser des moyens numériques
pour optimiser le notre utilisation de
l'énergie ou est-ce que les économies
qu'on pourrait faire non au sens de pour
le moment le numérique facilite les
usages facilite l'achat des billets
d'avion facilite l'achat des voitures
facilite le fait de vous faire livrer
des paires de chaussures que vous allez
à expédier si elles vous plaisent pas et
c'est donc aujourd'hui le numérique ne
facilite pas du tout la sobriété le
numérique ne facilite la sobriété que
s'il a un encadrement réglementaire qui
facilite la sobriété
alors c'est quoi un encadrement
réglementaire c'est d'interdire certains
usages par exemple il est interdit de
vendre des écrans ultra haute définition
parce que ça prouve très haut débit sur
les réseaux faut quand même savoir que
80 % du débit sur les réseaux dans le
monde c'est de la vidéo et ça se partage
en quatre quarts qui sont netflix et
consorts donc netflix a une empreinte
carbone qui est pas très loin de celle
du premier cimentier mondial
vous avez ensuite tout
youtube et consorts donc ce genre de
trucs le troisième succès le porno est
le quatrième quart c'est la vidéo du
petit dernier que votre cousine va vous
envoyer en vous disant regarde comme il
est beau voilà c'est à peu près ça les
quatre quarts des usages de la vidéo et
ça ça fait 80 % de l'empreinte carbone
pas ça fait 80 % de l usage des réseaux
dans le monde
bon tant que vous allez dire après la 4g
on va faire la 5g puis la cij et puis là
7 g puis machin etc
et puis les gens auront là dedans qui
pousse du petit dernier en ultra haute
définition
et bien c'est sûr que vous en sortez pas
donc il faut prendre le problème à
l'envers
donc si on veut de la sobriété numérique
en france par exemple le premier truc à
faire c'est de ne pas déployer la 5g ce
à quoi je suis favorable solide en
passant je pense pas que ça changera
fondamentalement le bonheur des français
ne pas déployer la 5g crois pas par
contre je pense que les problèmes que
j'ai évoqués çà çà va fondamentalement
changé le bonheur des français ça je me
suis sûr donc voilà donc vous pouvez en
gros à un moment il faut s'inventer dans
le problème en disant ça et ça et ça non
donc si les gens là dedans il leur reste
de l'espace pour faire de l'optimisation
des jeux pourquoi des pertes
alimentaires très bien mais on n'y
arrivera pas en dix ans la technique va
résoudre elle-même le problème si je
laisse les gens libres de faire
absolument ce qu'ils veulent
historiquement cela s'est toujours passé
de la manière inverse alors évidemment
la restriction pose un problème c'est
que comme c'est une restriction et c'est
désagréable en démocratie ça ne passe
que si une fraction significative de la
population a compris le problème et
accepte de la restriction
sinon ça passe pas bonjour j'avais une
question c'était par rapport au tout
traitement notamment politiques
voulaient savoir si vous avez encore
l'espoir que le politique puisse être
utile pour changer tout ça parce que
quand on voit un peu le traitement des
questions environnementales au wac s'est
beaucoup souvent l'idéologie très peu
des faits scientifiques qui sont
utilisés ou alors si c'est contre soi
c'est parce que il ya des lobbys est ce
que vous pensez que la science peut
s'inviter dans le politique est ce que
le politique fait encore utile ou et/ou
faut essayer de s'abstraire du politique
pour pouvoir lutter contre le changement
alors il ya plusieurs questions là
dedans est ce que la science est encore
utile oui alors faut faire attention là
aussi à ce qu'on appelle la science il
ya j'avais écrit il ya quelques années
un petit papier dans les échos qui
s'appelait les deux fiancés le politique
est alors en fait il ya eu six ans que
de politiques adorent c'est celle qui
est préfiguratrice des technologies donc
la science qu'on fait sur traitement du
signal je peux vous assurer que les
politiques adorent ça d'accord parce que
derrière macro on va pouvoir mettre ses
google classes'' par contre la science
qui est descriptive de l'état du monde
et qui vous dit que le dernier couple de
pie grièche a probablement disparu le
week-end dernier à celle là le politique
n'aime pas du tout donc en fait il faut
voir ce qu'on met dans la science c'est
clair que la science qui est descriptive
de l'état du monde
il faut et elle essaye de le faire
qu'elle s'invite plus dans le débat en
disant je vais vous poser les termes du
problème
le giec est un tour de force et un
quelque part c'est d'avoir réussi à
mettre ensemble des dizaines de
discipline scientifique parce que là
l'évolution du climat vous dites bras et
deux seules disciplines y est mais
qu'ils font non pas du tout il faut des
océanographes des vulcanologues des
géologues des chimistes de l'atmosphère
des dynamicien de l'atmosphère des
géochimistes palanquée disciplines
différentes qu'il a fallu faire bosser
ensemble
pour produire ce document de synthèse
donc la science c'est évident qu'elle a
intérêt à s'organiser alors on voit
aujourd'hui des tentatives il ya l'ipb
es maintenant qui s'est constitué sur la
biodiversité etc
donc c'est tout ça c'est bien c'est
utile et est ce que ça va changer de
politique la réponse est non donc
relisais tocqueville en démocratie alors
tant qu'on est en démocratie ce qui à
mon avis sera pas éternelle fassent sur
la tectonique des plaques que j'ai
décrit tant qu on est en démocratie le
politique ne réagit qu'à une seule chose
c'est les pressions on le voit bien dans
un domaine que je connais bien les 50%
de nucléaire en france ne correspondent
à rien d'autre qu'une sucette électorale
donné par hollande au vert pour se faire
élire c'est juste ça il n'y a pas plus
de réflexion derrière ce programme là tu
peux plus je peux vous assurer je
connais un peu le système de l'intérieur
des vies derrière on essaye de présenter
cela comme étant un truc intelligent
mais ce qui je couche et peut-être où je
pense que ça dépend mais c'est comme ça
que ça s'est décidé donc que fait le
politique et réagit à des pressions donc
si on veut que ce sujet là deviennent un
facteur de pression dans la décision
politique il faut s'organiser en
conséquence
je peux vous dire que le manifeste
étudiants est une organisation politique
c'est à dire que c'est un facteur de
pression pour orienter le comportement
d'une partie des gens qui sont en face
alors en route ça va être du billard à
deux bandes ce qui est en train de se
passer et parmi mes clients parce que je
vois bien c'est l'audience du manifeste
c'est à dire les chefs d'entreprises
auxquels on s'adresse à des clients
jeunes gens avec qui je discute
ils sont tous en ce moment en train de
se dire si jamais on fait pas ce qu'il
faut
les mecs qui vont filer ailleurs bon ce
qui est déjà en train de se passer soit
dit en passant
peut-être pas pour ces raisons là mais
je sais pas ce que je suis enseignant
aux mines comines
le taux d'emploi le tout premier emploi
dans les grands groupes a été divisé par
deux en l'espace de cinq ans c'est pas
beaucoup hein
enfin c'est beaucoup par deux essais pas
beaucoup cinq ans
donc le donc ça par exemple c'est un
élément de réponse
les l'entreprise 0 là il faut qu'on
commence à regarder ça à peu près et du
reste il faut tellement qu'on commence à
regarder ça dans à peu près qu'il y en a
un nombre croissant qui vont dire allez
il faut faire des trucs et à ce moment
le politique d'hier avant très bien
faisons des trucs la tribune du patron
lui-même dont là j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure c'était du pain béni pour moi
parce que il a très exactement repris un
truc qu'on a poussé au shift depuis la
dernière élection présidentielle qui est
sur une commission attali s'en attali
c'est à dire une commission ad-hoc pour
planifier la décarbonation dans laquelle
vous mettez tous les gens qui vont
devoir faire avec un contrôleur de
cohérence dont on revendiquait le poste
l'impression que les règles de trois
boucles à la fin et en disant voilà
comment on va s'organiser et puis si il
faut sortir des trucs du marché on va
commencer à gueuler pour que ça sorte du
marché pointe quoi on va planifier ça
que c'est ça que ça veut dire
les mises dans le marché d'un certain
nombre d'entités qui était régulée avant
ça a pas produit qui aurait dit un
résultat merveilleux en ce qui concerne
l'électricité et moi j'attends encore le
bénéfice de la faire première
conséquence est à par là où les prix
sont soutenus c'est un des
investissements massifs dans les
transports en grande bretagne n'a pas du
tout produit les résultats escomptés non
plus du reste ils sont dépêchés de
réguler dans l'autre sens c'est
quasiment renationaliser voilà donc il
ya des domaines dans lesquels on sait
très bien que les infractions relevant
qu elles ont rien à [ __ ] dans le
marché donc plus on fait une pression
sur les corps intermédiaires qui eux
mêmes au pouvoir faire pression sur le
politique est plus le schmilblick peu
avancé de s'aimer c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne
tant qu'on est en démocratie le jour on
y sera plus je vous donnerai pas la même
réponse je serai peut-être plus là pour
vous la donner mais mais en démocratie
c'est vraiment ça la règle du jeu c'est
qu'il faut qu'un nombre croissant de
gens disent moi je veux donc ça marche
si on parle alors personnellement si on
parle d'innovation et d'entrepreneuriat
j'ai peut-être abusivement tendance à
associer ça avec la consommation et la
croissance
donc en fait ce qui s'est passé pendant
cette présentation c'est que j'avais un
truc à l'écran est totalement
contradictoire
avec les trois banderoles à côté donc je
vais savoir si c'était un peu votre
point de vue sur un peu votre point de
vue sur cette politique de l'école
assure l'entrepreneuriat et la
croissance oui en partie
et sur ce que lourd tant qu'étudiant on
peut y faire alors je ne crois pas du
tout que l'entrepreneuriat soit hanté
nomique de la croissance ou vous
exactement soit ait besoin de la
croissance parce que tout dépend de ce
que ça remplace
j'ai quelques personnes dans mon
entourage alors ça reste des expériences
personnelles c'est pas quelque chose de
massif encore qu'il ya un mouvement qui
commence à se voir où vous avez des
cadres urbains qui retourne à la terre
et en général en faisant ça ils ont des
revenus qui baissent significativement
par rapport à ce qu'ils avaient avant
donc eux ils sont dans un processus
d'entrepreneuriat et d'innovation
parce qu'en général quand ils font ça
ils font un peu différemment des gens
qui étaient installés avant eux ou des
gens qui sont installés autour donc cet
entreprenariat c'est de l'innovation et
sarah pas besoin de la croissance
puisque ils baissent leurs revenus donc
je suis pas complètement sûr que ce soit
globalement quelque chose je vais
prendre un autre exemple plus
macroscopique les grandes structures
avec beaucoup de salariés n'existait pas
avant
l'énergie abondante la seule
multinationale qui existaient à l'époque
de l'énergie rare c'était l'église mais
je suis pas sûr qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'autres
si cela marchait bien cela étant le donc
les structures spatiales à large échelle
les entreprises qui font aujourd'hui 200
300 400 500 mille personnes dans un
monde dans lequel l'énergie est beaucoup
plus contrainte je suis pas complètement
sûr qu'elle continue à flotter parce
qu'elles ont besoin de flux internes
pour s'organiser qui sont extrêmement
importants elles ont besoin
si ces structures là s'affaiblissent
progressivement pour qu'on en revienne à
des structures plus artisanal plus etc
vous allez avoir plein d'entrepreneuriat
quelque part vous allez avoir plein
d'innovations parce qu'il va falloir
s'adapter à un contexte nouveau et ça se
fera pourtant dans un monde dans lequel
n'ya pas nécessairement de croissance
donc je suis pas complètement sûr voilà
par contre si la politique de l'école
s'est fait une licorne et faites-vous
cotées en bourse alors là c'est sûr que
ça marche pas passer sur moi j'ai
peut-être train encore un peu rabat joie
je suis ici et en fait pas tout ce que
vous avez dit par rapport à tout ce
qu'on entend en ce moment de plus en
plus je commence à me dire je vois pas
comment est-ce qu'on peut échapper à une
grosse guerre mondiale dans 10 ans ou 20
ans quel est votre avis un peu là dessus
est ce que vous pensez vraiment qu'il ya
un creux des solutions pour qu'on n'y
échappe
je crois pas tellement à la guerre
mondiale pour une raison assez simple
c'est que au fond aujourd'hui le
l'opposition qui est en train de se
créer c'est l'élite cosmopolite mondiale
contre les gens du bas de l'échelle et
l'élite cosmopolite mondial tient les
rênes du pouvoir dans tous les pays
donc pour qu'un pays prennent les armes
contre un autre pays il faudrait que par
un processus remontant le peuple d'un
pays et gect toutes ces élites
existantes les remplace par d'autres
beaucoup plus belliqueuse et décide
d'aller taper sur les voisins ça me
paraît pas la manière la plus probable
dont les dons les cristallisations les
oppositions peuvent apparaître ce que je
crois comme étant beaucoup plus probable
malheureusement comme facteur
déclencheur de conflit c'est des
conflits intra pays c'était des
migrations intra pays parce que les gens
crèvent de faim ici on qui se déplace là
c'est des conflits enfin des micros
guérilla urbaine qui sont durs est en
train d'apparaître dans un certain
nombre de pays c'est à dire c'est des
trucs interne
éventuellement je pense que pour avoir
le retour des conflits de pays à pays il
faudra d'abord voir le retour des
régimes totalitaires et à 10 ans j'y
crois quand même pas trop ok merci ça me
rassure mais c'est un risque
c'est clair que c'est un risque voyant
les anneaux génération de télé comme
hier on est de plus en plus sensibles au
développement durable
ai je voulu savoir justement vous dites
que numérique basse en fait ça pollue
énormément
qu'est ce qu'un telle commun qui est
sensible justement la transition
énergétique et à vouloir être acteur la
terre monde meilleur quel genre de
métier pourrait-il faire pour et bien
c'est vous qui allez trouver la réponse
parce que c'est très très rare qu'on
fasse un métier dont on n'est pas
convaincu soi même que c'est sinon le
meilleur possible au moins une option
possible
et cette conclusion on irait toujours
par soi même c'est à dire que c'est pas
parce que vos parents vous dise tu vas
faire cordonnier que vous auriez
nécessairement très envie de faire
cordonnier du reste je pense qu'il ya
quelques personnes qui ont eu quelques
crises d'adolescence dans cette salle
donc c'est pas toujours les plus avides
et par an on suit c'est pas parce que
vos avis vous dira donc il ya un
ensemble de facteurs qui font qu'un jour
vous aurez envie ou pas envie de faire
un truc ça va plus vous avez plutôt
procéder par élimination et surtout de
toute façon votre propre conviction vous
allez vous l'a forgée au terme d'un
processus qui est toujours le même qui
est un pro c'est une démarche
personnelle dans laquelle vous allez
poser 25 questions plus exactement 500
questions à 500 personnes différentes
et puis un jour vous vous direz pas
c'est ça que je veux faire c'est en
général comme ça que ça marche
je ne crois pas du tout au fait que l'on
vous dise attendez vous appelez comment
vous est blond vous êtes brin vous
mesurez quoi et c est ce que vous
préférez les cheese cake ou les tartes
aux pommes
ah bah page 453 ya le métier pour vous
je crois pas du tout donc ça viendra
comme ça viendra c'est par contre qui
est important c'est de continuer cette
démarche dans laquelle vous vous posez
des questions en vous disant et si et
sarah ici et ça
comme ça que ça arrive numérique sera
vrai même au sein du numérique alors je
vais vous donner deux ou trois exemples
on a travaillé au chai 44 pour un acteur
qui utilisent
vous avez deux acteurs dans le domaine
des smartphones par exemple qui font
quelque chose qui est plutôt mieux que
la moyenne qui sont des gens qui
fabrique des smartphones réparable donc
en gros vous n'avez pas les trucs tous
soudés sur une carte mère vous êtes un
foutu et c'est donc vous êtes capable de
remplacer des composants pris un par un
et vous avez des gens qui reconditionne
des smartphones qui sont pas réparables
mais eux en usine ils prennent pilsen
pisseuses de trucs qui marchent plus et
ils ont refondé être qui marche qui ne
sont toujours pas réparable mais en
euros ils ont un peu voilà des activités
qui tout bien pesé sont au mieux que ce
que ça remplace d'accord ça veut pas
dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
qui évite la pollution numérique entre
guillemets de croître de manière forte
deuxième sujet vous pouvez rentrer dans
des instances de régulation
c'est à vous pouvez vous dire bah oui à
un moment il va quand même bien falloir
à tenir raisonnable arrêtez de penser
que après la 3 152 g on va faire l'a350
3g et donc vous rentrez dans des
endroits où vous posez la question de
savoir qu'est ce qu'on met comme limite
au système ou qu'est ce qu'on met comme
règle de fonctionnement au système pour
pas qu'ils dérivent
voilà donc il ya mai mais ça vous allez
je le redis cdc des trucs qui vont vous
apparaître à force de poser des
questions et une question qu'on amène
une autre ce n'est pas de il faut que ce
soit une démarche personnelle j'insiste
vraiment là-dessus si c'est un truc qui
vous tombent ex cathedra de toute façon
vous achèterez pas si vous étiez à notre
place
ou est-ce que vous iriez habiter dans le
monde pour souffrir le moins possible et
plus tard et bien c'est une excellente
question et je vous remercie de l'avoir
posée
il n'y a pas de réponse évidente à cette
question non plus il n'y a pas de
réponse évidente à cette question alors
je vais commencer par une anecdote j'ai
eu ya pas très longtemps une et chants
en échange avec une néo zélandaise qui
me dit il ya des tas de gens qui
commencent à acheter des propriétés chez
nous ok enfin en nouvelle zélande
vous n'avez pas de puits de pétrole vous
avez pas de raffinerie vous n'avez pas
d'industries chimiques
je suis pas sûr que vous ayez beaucoup
de métallurgie c'est donc
imaginons que ce soit le cas partout si
vous allez vivre en nouvelle zélande
vous élèverez des moutons parce qu'il y
aura pas de bagnole et pas d'internet
d'accord donc puisque c'est fabriqué
ailleurs avec des éléments qu'on trouve
ailleurs
donc là la réponse à cette question elle
est compliquée parce que tout le monde
se dit ben je vais aller dans un endroit
où je vais préserver ce que je fais
aujourd'hui dans les grandes lignes
mais sauf que ce que vous êtes
dépend pour plein plein d' usage de
trucs qui sont hyper mondialisée enfin
je veux dire les ordinateurs et les
téléphones à vous laver les quatre
fabricants dans le monde
les composants les dalles d'écrans je
pense que vous devez avoir trois
fabricants dans le monde enfin bon donc
vous avez des tas de trucs sur lesquels
aujourd'hui le en fait même si vous êtes
très très loin de l'autre côté de la
terre vous continuer à dépendre pour une
bonne partie de votre confort de choses
qui se trouve à un deux trois quatre
endroits dans le monde
un autre exemple le lithium pour les
batteries vous avez quatre producteurs
dans le monde qui font 90 % de la
production mondiale
il n'a pas changé beaucoup parce qu'ils
ont aussi 95% des réserves donc vous
avez comme ça donc donc la question elle
ne peut pas se poser autrement que de
façon systémique c'est-à-dire admettons
que ça commence à aller mal ou est-ce
que dans le monde je suis le mieux
couverts et tant que ça va pas mal
est-ce que c'est aussi dans cet endroit
là que je serais content de vivre en
attendant que sa rivale la réponse est
pas nécessairement oui enfin je veux
dire c'est pas nécessairement un peu mes
cahiers des charges dans les deux cas de
figure dernier point ce qui empêche que
ça aille trop mal quelles que soient les
conditions extérieures
c'est un truc qui ne s'appelle pas
compter sur ses propres forces mais qui
s'appelle la coopération en fait les
mondes contraint son démon très
coopératif la raison pour laquelle les
pays scandinaves et la suisse sont les
pays les plus consensuelles en europe
c'est parce que c'était les pays dans
lesquels la vie était le plus difficile
il ya un siècle
le paysan enfin la suisse était le pays
le plus pauvre d'europe occidentale
avant guerre les pays scandinaves il
fallait se palucher l'hiver je veux dire
avant que vous ayez le chauffage central
l'électricité et la télévision pour vous
aiguiller
il y avait rien à bouffer il fallait
être sûr que les stocks allaient tenir
allons donc c'est des pays qui ont
développé des modes d'organisation qui
sont terriblement consensuelle parce que
justement c'était des sociétés qui
étaient très contrainte
donc la réponse à la question c'est
aussi aller dans des endroits dans
lesquels vous pensez qu'une coopération
très forte sera capable de s'exercer
pour résister à des soubresauts
significatif des conditions extérieures
et ça c'est une affaire de culture du
pays dont je peux vous dire que le
dernier pays il faut aller dans ce genre
de contexte et les états unis la
coopération c'est quand même pas
vraiment leur corps qui fait quoi
la structure collectif c'est quand même
pas vraiment leur qui fallait donc voila
mais mais mais une fois que je vous ai
dit ça je ne vous ai répondu qu'à moitié
parce que je vous ai donné quelques
éléments auxquels il faut être attentif
et je me garderai bien de vous dire
allez donc dans la partie nord-ouest de
l'australie c'est là que tout va changer
en même temps donc c'est aussi ça qui
est difficile
vous pouvez très bien prendre le
problème à l'envers et vous dire je
reste en france un patou je suis
français je parle cette langue c'est ça
ma culture et je vais essayer de faire
en sorte que mon pays devienne
coopératif résilient compas de ce genre
de problème etc
c'est aussi une très bonne voie de
sortie avant la vie peut-être une
question sur l'économie vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure le fait que vous pouviez
développer sur les graphes le feq les le
pib n'étaient pas corrélés avec le prix
du pétrole et d'autres
vous avez évoqué d'autres choses comme
ça que vous pouviez développer ça
m'intéresse
comment de manière plus générale vous
pouvez expliquer à ce point cette
déclaration non pas entre l'économie et
la réalité mais entre la finance et la
réalité pourquoi les prix et la pensée
que le marché peut s'autoréguler est à
ce point déficiente
il ya plein de gens qui ont écrit plein
de trucs sur le sujet je vais vous
donner un petit bric à brac de quelques
réflexions personnelles
la première c'est que quand une
ressource est essentielle au
fonctionnement de l'économie
or les transports sont essentiels au
fonctionnement de l'économie je le redis
pas de transport pas d'économie il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui une unité productive qui
rassemble en un même lieu les matériaux
de base qui lui sont nécessaires toutes
les opérations de transformation
intermédiaires plus le consommateur car
pas besoin de se déplacer parce qu'il
est sur place vous avez ça si vous
faites pousser des tomates dans votre
jardin
et c'est à peu près tout quoi bon ce qui
veut dire que tout le système économique
fonctionne avec des transports
intermédiaire donc la quantité de
transport que vous avez est un facteur
limitant du fonctionnement du système
moins de pétrole
physiquement c'est moins de transports
dont vous avez une limitation de votre
production alors économiquement comment
ça va se passer si vous avez moins de
pétrole comme c'est aussi une commodité
dans un premier temps le prix va
exploser donc les gens vont moins en
acheter donc ils vont se priver de
transport donc le pib va se contracter
puisque vous avez moins de transport à
ce moment vous aurez aussi moins de gens
qui ont envie d'acheter du pétrole et à
ce moment vous aurez modifié à la fois
l'offre et la demande et le prix se
stabilisent ou pas ailleurs que là où il
était au début quand vous voyez vous
avez un mécanisme auto correctifs parce
que le pib et le pétrole sont asservis
physiquement si la commodité et est
indépendante du pib c'est à dire que le
monde n'a pas besoin de cette commodité
pour fonctionner à ce moment c'est clair
que vous avez une élasticité qui marche
beaucoup mieux
les gens gagnent plus d'argent ils en
achètent plus ils gagnent moins d'argent
ils ont lâché enfin ça marche assez bien
mais quand cet élément est indispensable
au fonctionnement de l'économie
physiquement à ce moment le truc se
passe dans les deux sens et dont vous
avez un phénomène aussi à thouars qui se
met en place et qui rattrape les prix et
qui les empêchent de monter indéfiniment
dit autrement si les prix n'explosent
pas à la pompe comme l'on demandait déjà
un milliard de gens par mail c'est tout
simplement parce que si vous avez un
problème sur le pétrole vous avez un
problème sur l'économie à ce moment vous
avez moins d'automobilistes
je schématise mais c'est ça l'idée en ce
qui concerne le il y avait une deuxième
question qui était serré sur la finance
alors sur la finance un premier élément
de réponse il ya des gens qui ont écrit
là-dessus c'est que les marchés parfait
n'existe pas si les marchés étaient
parfaits c'est à dire que si tous les
gens dans cette salle avait la même
information exhaustive et complète sur
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui est ce qui
va se passer demain les prix ne
varierait pas personne ne serait
d'accord parce qu'un prix qui varient
sur un marché c'est un pari sur l'avenir
qui est fait de façon différente
par les gens qui achètent des parts les
gens qui vendent mais si tout le monde
pense que c'est exactement la même chose
qui va se passer
dispose de toute l'information pour être
sûr que c'est comme ça que ça va se
passer quoi voulez où les prix changent
puisque un instant t vous connaissez
déjà toute l'information embarqué pour
le futur
donc entre eta et est plus un la
quantité d'informations dont vous
disposez n'a pas changé puisque vous
savez déjà tout sur le futur et vous
avez une information par fait d'accord
donc si l'information des agents on n'a
pas changé
le prix n'a pas de raison de changer
puisque le prix atteint 0 en cas en
barque est déjà tout ce qui se passe à
l'avenir donc le fait que les prix
varient c'est par construction par
démonstration presque la conséquence du
fait que justement l'information n'est
pas parfaitement partagé
justement c'est la raison pour laquelle
le délit d'initié est un peu une
hypocrisie quelque part les gens qui
gagnent en bourse c'est toujours des
gens qui ont bénéficié d'une information
d'un degré de fiabilité supérieure et
d'une pertinence supérieur par rapport à
leurs petits copains donc appeler ça du
délit d'initié dans certains cas et pas
dans d'autres sur les jésuites riz pour
moi un vrai rebond mais la barrière il à
faire des conventions
la raison se fa la la vérité c'est que
tous les coups gagnants sont des initiés
quelque part ça vous savez quelque chose
que les autres savent pas s'ils vont ils
pas rire est comme vous donc il aurait
pas de paris après pourquoi est-ce-que
alors après si on rentre dans les
mécanismes techniques de variation des
prix sur les marchés en fonction des
quantités disponibles là on sort de mon
domaine de compétence
donc moi la seule chose que je suis
capable de vous dire c'est les marchés
parfait n'existe pas donc le fait que
les marchés ne se comporte pas comme des
marchés parfait c'est normal jusque là
y'a rien qui bétonnent après qu'est ce
qui fait que techniquement ça va se
passer plutôt comme ceux ci à tel moment
où plutôt comme cela at-elle au talent
ça je m'en sors de mon domaine de
compétence
moi je constate de constater qu' il n'y
a pas de relation univoque et facilement
caractérisable entre prix et volumes et
ça suffira démonstration pas besoin
d'aller plus loin
bonjour
vous évoquez est alors que les élites
politiques sont réfugiées seulement à
court terme et sont piégés un peu dans
leurs intérêts économiques
est-ce que du coup le chaos enfin le
chaos est en quelque sorte écologique
est inévitable ou est ce qu'il serait
possible comme vous l'évoquez tout à
l'heure avec la révolution française qui
est un mouvement populaire qui puisse
paraître d'art et essai de nathan et
quelque soit apporter des solutions
un peu plus tôt que prévu en quelque
sorte alors d'abord le changement ne
vient pas nécessairement que par la
révolution ils peuvent venir par la
révolution mais en général ça se termine
sur un bain de sang c'est pas
nécessairement mieux derrière et
quelques exemples historiques
il peut aussi venir de manière plus
graduelle et il ya un pays qui est très
intéressant de ce point de vue qui est
la grande bretagne qui s'est débarrassé
de sa monarchie constitutionnelle sans
faire la révolution qui s'est aussi
débarrassé de l'esclavagisme sans faire
la révolution donc il n'y a pas que la
révolution comme mode de commode de
changement est-ce que je vais refaire la
réponse que j'ai fait tout à l'heure
c'est à dire qu'est ce qui fait que le
monde politique change le monde
politique change parce que il ya une
pression de la société qui fait qu' il
se dit qu'il doit changer
[Musique]
c'est aussi bête que ça
et toutes les associations militantes
tout
qu'il s'agisse de défendre les intérêts
de la chimie ou greenpeace ont tout
comme seul et unique objectif de
mobiliser en leur faveur
une partie des corps intermédiaires ou
de l'opinion publique qui va pouvoir
faire pression sur le monde politique
donc tout le monde joue au même jeu qui
est mobilisé une partie des gens dont
les politiques dépendent pour se faire
élire il joue touche au même jeu moi
inclus à ma modeste échelle avec des
chiffres gect juste d'après votre
présentation donc le futur ingénieur
télécoms bien il fera pas vraiment
d'ingénierie développera pas la 5g ou la
6 g âgé pas dis ça je dis que ça serait
pas une bonne idée ça de mon point de
vue d'un point de vue moral doit au fait
est ce qu'il sera plus enfin ce sera
plus un politique le futur ingénieur de
demain qu'est-ce qui fera alors ce que
j'espère mais je vais rebondir sur la
réponse que je fais tout à l'heure
j'espère d'abord que il aura un débat
que moi je n'ai pas eu dans ma
génération qui est mais je crois qu'il
est en train d'émerger très fort dans la
vôtre qui est un débat ce justement sur
c'est quoi la place dans la société
moi à mon époque les gens s'en foutait
c'est à dire que les gens avaient des
parcours personnels les uns sont partis
s'en foutent plein les fouilles dans la
banque les autres regarder faire du cul
nu dans la recherche parce qu'il y avait
un truc il est passionnel les autres
encore faire des reportages en afrique
parce qu'il trouvait que c'était ça qui
était rigolo peu de gens se sont posé
dans ma génération la question de
l'utilité sociale de ce qu'ils allaient
faire ça je crois que c'est un fait
assez nouveau dans la vôtre et c'est
plutôt très encourageant de mon point de
vue c'est finalement enfin bon je sais
pas si vous êtes représentatif de
l'ensemble de la provo mais les gens qui
m'ont posé des questions mais il ya
quand même un il n'y a pas une quête
personnelle sur sa place dans la société
qui s'oppose de façon très différente de
la façon dont ma génération de
jouisseurs s'est posé la question nous
c'était on en avait jusque derrière les
oreilles les plus rentables et plus on
était content
le la réponse elle est exactement la
même que celle que j'ai fait avant c'est
à dire que il ya qu une démarche
personnelle qui vous amènera à la
réponse donc la bonne nouvelle c'est que
vous êtes ici pour trois ans donc si
vous n'avez ni guerre ni révolution ni
famine ni météorites qui se casse la
gueule sur la planète ni pourquoi vous
avez quand même un peu de temps devant
vous pour répondre à la question donc
profité de ce temps pour renifler à
droite à gauche
retourner le problème dans tous les sens
et comme vous êtes des gens intelligents
vous finirez par trouver quelque chose
[Musique]
du coup justement par rapport à ce que
vous venez de dire il ya beaucoup de
gens je pense qu'ils ne peuvent pas
prendre justement le temps de faire des
recherches parce que tout simplement ils
n'ont pas été éduqués mais en démocratie
cette partie de la population celle qui
est la plus grand qui la plus grande
celle qui votent donc ben pour sauver la
terre est ce que la démocratie c'est
vraiment le bon plan bah je vais vous
faire la même réponse que celle de
churchill
c'est la pire des systèmes à l'exclusion
de tous les autres alors je c'est une
vraie question que je me suis posé
souvent et angers peut être vous choquer
mais je me suis demandé si le système
chinois n'était pas un meilleur
compromis de long terme c'est à dire
qu'un système dans lequel il ya une
mainmise politique qui est quand même
beaucoup plus forte
mais quand même une forme de liberté
individuelle qui est loin d'être
négligeable je veux dire c'est quand
même les gens sont quand même pas tous
en prison en chine alors vu des
démocraties occidentales on se dit si un
scandale les libertés sont compris sauf
que là sauf que la règle collective
c'est une privation de liberté je veux
dire quand on dit aux fumeurs vous ne
suivrez pas dans les lieux publics c'est
une privation de liberté la liberté du
fumeurs de fumer dans les lieux publics
à l'opposé du spectre on trouve les
états unis où vous avez des libertariens
c'est à dire des gens qui pensent qu'on
doit absolument rien d'interdire de rien
du tout aux individus
donc j'ai eus sont libres de faire
absolument tout ce qu'ils veulent mais
c'est un système dans lequel vous avez
du mal à organiser des efforts
collectifs autre que ceux qui sont
guidés par l'intérêt de court terme
partager mais c'est une vraie question
donc il me semble que on a besoin en
tout cas de mettre des éléments 1 de
décision et de stabilisation dans le
monde dans lequel on vit alors j'en vois
pas d'autres en partant du système dans
lequel on est que d'essayer de forger
des consensus dans la société civile
pour que le politiques agissent en
conformité
vous avez parfaitement raison de dire
que l'information est un sujet crucial
moi il ya un truc que je dis souvent à
mes étudiants et donc que je vais vous
répéter
enfin les élèves aux mines qui est vous
avez été vous êtes rentré dans cette
école en ayant été sélectionnés sur
votre aptitude à répondre à des
problèmes qui sont posés de manière
exacte avec une solution univoque tous
les problèmes que vous aurez dans la vie
sont posées de façon partielle et de
travers avec plusieurs solutions
possibles tous d'accord donc sur tous
comme ça donc
et c'est une c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut garder bien bien présent à l'esprit
est alors donc leurs poils que je
voulais présenter ce soir fait partie de
ces problèmes présentés de travers
souvent que la presse je pense pas que
vous croyez vous que vous croyez pas
vous serez au moins d'accord avec moi
sur le fait que la présentation ce
prêtre dans la presse n'est pas
exactement raccord est ce que je vous ai
raconté soir
donc moi je considère puisque je
conseillerais à langer raison que le
problème est posé de travers dans la
presse donc vous aurez à faire toute
votre vie durant à les problèmes posés
de travers avec des gens qui sont peu ou
mal ou informés de travers il va falloir
faire avec ce que ce que vous pouvez
faire c'est participer à la diffusion de
l'information est aujourd'hui il ya des
initiatives qui commencent à émerger en
ce sens alors sur vous avez peut-être
entendu parler certains d'entre vous de
la fresque du climat qui est une
initiative qui a été lancé par un homme
avec qui j'ai collaboré pendant sept ans
qui a été directeur de chiffres project
et il a laissé une manière ludique
d'apprendre le contenu de ce qu'il ya
dans les rapports du giec et là il ya
plein d'école où il en a science po là
j'ai été faire une conférence de rentrée
aussi la semaine dernière et l'après
midi toute la promo jouer à la fresque
du climat donc il faut trois quatre
heures donc ça c'est donc ça c'est un
partage de l'information et bien ce truc
là il est déclinable pour des gens qui
sont entre guillemets qu'on pas eu la
chance de faire des études supérieures
où on n'avait pas les capacités parce
que c'est un truc qui est modulable et
adaptable aux capacités de chacun
et puis c'est un truc virale cirque les
gens qui ont déjà fait peuvent devenir
animateur et puis le faire à leur place
leur tour avec d'autres etc
vous pouvez très bien participer à des
initiatives comme ça derrière donc voilà
donc il ya un sujet de partage de
l'information
c'est évident que on a c'est quelque
chose de très utile et c'est évident que
ça permet les gens n'étant pas
complètement idiot en tout cas de mieux
poser le problème
je vais finir par une anecdote j'ai fait
une intervention de cette nature il ya
quelques années devant des syndicalistes
en l'occurrence de la cfdt d'une branche
d'activité en france
je leur ai raconté que on allait avoir
du mal à préserver le pouvoir d'achat
pour le compte du futur à cause de la
contraction énergétique qui allait
s'appliquer de gré ou de force dont
degré si on veut limiter le changement
climatique et de force même si on veut
part parce que les complices y trouve
des puits sable
je me suis dit je vais me faire sortir
un grand coup de pied dans le derrière
et pas du tout j'ai trouvé une audience
très désireuse de discuter assez battu
race etc
donc je suis très profondément
convaincus du fait que quand on explique
aux gens qu'on a un problème et pourquoi
on a un problème il vous sortent pas des
serments à grand coup de pied dans le
derrière et y en a un certain nombre qui
ont envie de discuter
donc c'est très utile d'aller diffuser
l'information mais pas denis
comment dire pas de donner des leçons
sur ce qu'il faut faire derrière déjà de
2,2 de faire comprendre aux gens comment
on arrive à poser le problème
voilà ça c'est un bon début en tout cas
bonjour merci pour cette conférence
j'avais une question par rapport par
rapport aux débuts du dérèglement
climatique en fait je me demandais si
initialement les humains avaient pris
des mesures responsables vis-à-vis du
des émissions en carbone
est ce que on serait arrivé à l'état
climatiques actuelles et auquel cas donc
si on fait le bilan climatique c'est pas
une fatalité qu'on peut pas vraiment
éviter c'est une question intéressante
parce que il faut définir ce qu'on
appelle une fatalité une fatalité
donc si une fatalité c'est notre code
génétique qui fait qu'on ait des animaux
accumulatif aux accumulateurs j'ai pas
comment on dit et court termiste parce
qu'on est gouvernée par nos sens et que
nos sens nous font agir en mode et ses
erreurs
quand donc quand on a fait une grosse
connerie il s'en rend compte qu'après
coup eh bien oui c'est une forme de
fatalité on est victime de notre succès
c'est à dire que d'autres câblage
biologique fait qu'on ait des animaux
qui ont trop bien réussi et donc on a
bouffé tout l'espace et on est en train
de [ __ ] en l'air la boîte de pétri si
vous vous dites non non on peut prendre
de la hauteur de vue sauf qu'on est en
train de faire mais c'est une hypothèse
a redit à ce moment on aurait
effectivement pu éviter mais au prix
d'une utilisation des combustibles
fossiles albin michel et donc l'humanité
aujourd'hui aura une taille plus petite
ça c'est sûr moins de pouvoir d'achat
c'est sûr aussi les sauf que l'on fera
pas l'expérience donc maintenant il faut
faire avec ce qu'on a
mais on a un vrai sujet psychologique
derrière il ya des gens aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont en train dans ma bande
d'ingénieur à carbonne quatre là qu'ils
sont en train de se passionner pour ce
qu'on appelle l'écopsychologie c'est à
dire ce qui permet de comprendre les
ressorts psychologiques qui nous anime
qui font que on a tendance à se
comporter d'une certaine manière à un
peu zappé
l'intérieur du terrier dans lequel on
est et ccd lecture assez utile parce que
c'est parce que de comprendre pourquoi
on se comporte comment se comportent et
une des clés de lecture qu'il faut avoir
pour essayer de changer quelque chose
parce qu'on n'a pas compris qu est ce
qui nous poussait à faire ça c'est
compliqué d'agir dessus excusez-moi
dernière dernière question s'il vous
plaît le dernier a eu très très court
vous avez déjà proposé un plan de ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour vous et vous
avez dit par exemple que le modèle de
lachine vous semble et pertinents au vu
de ce qu'on peut trouver sur internet
avec des personnes qui pensent plutôt
s'organiser vers des petites sociétés
pour tout ce qui est logique de société
résiliente société auto autour pas
génératrice mais qui s'auto gère quoi
est-ce que ça vous semble pertinent et
si oui dans quel cas est ce que ça
pourrait mener deux gros projets étant
donné qu'on serait limité par la taille
alors c'est quelque chose qui dépend du
sujet dont on parle donc effectivement
rapprocher les ressources de là où elles
sont utilisées
c'est un facteur de résilience alors il
ya des domaines dans lesquels c'est
facile et des domaines dans lesquels
c'est plus difficile
paradoxalement on a commencé en france à
s'attaquer au problème de la façon qui
est la plus difficile j'ai envie de dire
puisque l'autonomie qui est la première
qui vient à l'esprit de tout le monde
c'est énergétique est en fait comme je
disais tout à l'heure énergie il ya
l'électricité est en fait les gens
pensent autonomie électrique
alors pour l'autonomie électrique c'est
quand même un peu compliqué parce que si
vous devez avoir sur place toute
l'électricité qui vous permet de
fonctionner nuitées jour etc vous avez
besoin de panneaux les dix premiers sur
les dix premiers producteurs de panneaux
sont en chine ce que vous êtes autonome
quand vous dépendez en totalité pour un
truc soi-disant local de quelque chose
qui est produit en totalité à dix mille
kilomètres de vos frontières
ça se discute toutes les éoliennes sont
faites aujourd'hui en chine en allemagne
et un peu au danemark même motif mais
toutes les batteries sont faites en
dehors de france tout à la fin donc
est-ce que vous êtes autonome
quand le système que vous mettez en
place le peut être mis en place qu'avec
des trucs qui sont faits très loin et ne
peut être maintenue qu'avec des trucs
qui sont faits très loin parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'il faut remplacer quelque
chose ça vient du même endroit ma
réponse est on par contre il ya des
domaines dans lesquels vous pouvez être
plus autonome c'est-à-dire vous pouvez
remplacer le la pizza surgelée que vous
acheter au supermarché qui a
effectivement été faite loin et c'est
par un bout de poulet acheté chez
l'éleveur du coin et trois patates
acheté chez les maraîchers du coin
donc il ya un domaine dans lequel vous
pouvez accroître la résilience c'est la
nourriture
ça c'est très clair et en particulier
pour toutes les communes rurales
c'est quelque chose d'intéressant il ya
un deuxième domaine dans lequel vous
pouvez accroître la résilience c'est
pour tous les produits en bois
il n'y a pas de raison aujourd'hui
d'exporter des grumes dont transformer
et de rien emporter des produits
transformés ont fait en france le
deuxième poste de déficit de la balance
commerciale était ya quelques années
maintenant je me demande si l'automobile
est en train de passer devant mais
étaient les meubles vous avez des la
résilience peut s'organiser en rendant
les objets plus réparable typiquement au
moins quand j'avais ma grand mère était
couturière et grand mère était
couturière
quand j'étais gamin les chemises elles
étaient reprises et les vestes avait des
pièces au coude dire que quand vous
aviez un trou au coude vous jetez pas la
baisse pour aller en acheter une autre
reprise y est la veste vous mettiez une
pièce et alors que c'était pas terrible
j'étais moche ce qu'on voulait mais en
attendant c'est est plus résilient donc
là la réparabilité voilà la capacité à
réparer c'est aussi quelque chose qui
augmente la résilience donc faux mais à
chaque fois il faut réfléchir un petit
peu système c'est à dire que si on se
dit je vais remplacer un truc qui vient